[Laughter]
hey it's us we're sitting here eating
cheese crackers i know
yeah munching on [ __ ] at least we're not
too close to the microphone so like
they're called munchables was the brand
munchies munchies wasn't that a horror
movie in the 1980s i feel like in the
1980s they had ghoulies and munchies and
um
uh
that's probably about it got them from
dollar general store bob goblin yeah we
kind of get most things from dollar
general because it's right there it's
right there i mean you know yeah they
don't have everything but they have most
things that you would kind of need
although last night like last time we
went though
they didn't have a lot of
cookie selection no they're the trucks
aren't coming
yeah so it's kind of like hit or miss
like sometimes they have [ __ ] and
sometimes they don't yeah but
i don't know you you can usually buy it
evidently there's like supply chain
problems well yeah so they don't restock
some [ __ ]
but
i don't know i normally would just it's
just i still found some granola bars and
some decent coffee and yeah
[ __ ] like that so i was happy got some
drano let's see
they're all starting to [ __ ] pile in
as soon as we start as soon as we start
streaming everybody wants to show up
they don't want to wait well yeah they
don't want to wait they just want us to
start streaming and they come in
oral calls in how you doing oracle
maniacs in
all right
[ __ ] maniac says he could have seen
nick cave and [ __ ] yeah
he messaged me i just saw that message
like probably half an hour ago and i was
just like god damn it
i'm still mad that i never got to see
him
that sucks yeah i went down to the biker
bar today
yeah
yeah
i almost got into an argument about
motorcycles but i [ __ ] let it go oh i
haven't heard this story yet he was
telling me before he was telling me
about the jukebox yeah and how it's like
controlled with the phone app now shoot
but the jukebox was controlling my mind
before that [ __ ] was happening
a friend of mine pulled up
on a [ __ ] ducati multistrada
that's a [ __ ] almost almost
thousand dollar motorcycle
one of these dudes on a [ __ ] harley
says oh that old piece of [ __ ] and i
went wait a minute hold on hold on a
ducati's a piece of [ __ ]
a ducati is a piece of [ __ ] i knew the
dude pulled up and he wanted to start
backing down a little bit and so if his
bike's a piece of [ __ ] is my bike a
piece of [ __ ]
because you know
i got a couple of buells and i was like
how many bikes do you have and turns out
he's got one all right
and like look man that [ __ ]
pulled up in the ducati multistrada he's
got a harley at his house
okay and then all of a sudden they
wanted to they wanted to [ __ ] like
back up oh well that's not what i meant
no that's exactly what you bet
they got dudes with one bike it's a
harley calling other [ __ ] that
their bike's a piece of [ __ ] well i kind
of want to start fighting over this you
know i'm like
my women hold on he's got more than one
bike okay
you're thinking along stereotypes you
know he's got more than one bike and he
knows more about motorcycles than you
you only got one bike and he's got
[ __ ] three okay
don't say that that bike is a piece of
[ __ ] it's worth twice what your harley's
worth
you know but you know whatever well
that's one thing though i kind of feel
like
it's like middle school it's like high
school well yeah one that's what i was
gonna say it's just like you know don't
get in fights about [ __ ] that's like
right yeah that's like chocolate [ __ ]
but also
also um
why do you even like want like don't
even comment like on other people's [ __ ]
i don't understand like why like i'm
sorry did nobody asked for your opinion
did they i don't i don't remember
anything he's trying to be all so keep
your [ __ ] mouth he's trying to be all
hard ass [ __ ] harley biker yeah
and i'm looking at his [ __ ] doughboy
ass and i'd [ __ ] him up you know what i
mean but while i'm and then i'm trying
to check myself you know yeah i'm
injecting weird [ __ ] [ __ ] kind of
makes me aggressive like why am i
beating one motherfucker's ass behind
another motherfucker's ass bike
you know what's all about like well i'm
glad i'm defending the honor of another
man's motorcycle
i'm glad that you had that moment of
clarity i was like wait
i'm getting ready to fight a guy over
another guy's motorcycle can you imagine
the epic eye roll that would have been
sued on my part yeah if you could if i
had got a phone call and you were in
jail yeah and it wasn't even and
somebody insulting your bike which would
still be stupid but it was just kind of
like some yeah that is not even like
right and it's like you you don't even
have a dog in that fight right no and
then you just like got your ass kicked
or you kicked someone else's ass
everybody
more likely not to kick that dude's ass
you'd like knocked his teeth out wait
i'm suing you and [ __ ] and then i'm just
kind of like
i'm not dumb i don't fight another dude
unless i can win
you know i didn't have children for a
reason okay i don't need to i don't need
that kind of [ __ ] i'm just saying don't
ever [ __ ] call me a jig if you it
yeah too much money to break you did
that kind of [ __ ] don't call me no call
call somebody they can't just
it just would have been a simple bad air
battery i'd be out in a week anyway this
is the battery i'd be out in about a
week and that's week that's a week's
worth of me not spending any of my money
so that's okay i don't know that's a
whole week worth of me telling pookie
what a dummy her dad is yeah
just sleeping up here in central
sleeping
oh my god yeah i had to [ __ ] talk to
[ __ ] i had to talk to my side i had to
talk to my friend sod up in saudi arabia
i'm like man i almost beat a
motherfucker's ass over somebody else's
motorcycle
what's wrong with me yeah yeah i hadn't
checked myself well like i said i'm glad
i'm glad that i'm glad that you at least
realized that
that you're not still
like that you didn't come home like
still mad about it i got free drinks
behind it though
so it was a win-win for everybody yeah i
got free drinks that's a win-win for
everybody yeah but like i said i really
don't understand another [ __ ]
behind i don't i really don't understand
this
compulsion it's not everybody but a lot
of people have this weird compulsion to
like
share their opinions with those like
about something that's like nothing to
do with them and i'm like
no nobody asked you right it's like so
why is your opinion relevant in this
situation no harley davidsons are great
the new ones they're [ __ ] fantastic
they make a lot of torque
a lot of good street power
uh very little trouble on the motor real
good gas economy it's not the only game
in town though it's not the uh it's not
the only kind of motorcycle you can have
i mean some dudes that's all they want
to ride but there are other guys that
want more than that i mean what what's
wrong with dirt bikes you even have a
dirt bike you wouldn't have a harley and
a dirt bike you wouldn't have a harley a
dirt bike and a sport bike or a harley a
dirt bike a sport bike and a [ __ ]
street fighter you know i don't
understand this well i can only have
what one motorcycle type
that's not me
i like i like a little bit of everything
i'm getting ready to build a [ __ ]
harley
i didn't i didn't tell you about that
i'm thinking about it
i got an n with a club that has a bunch
of parts
oh fascinating yeah up here well yeah
you've been like talking about doing
that because you had that one that you
you had that one that you were working
on that you never finished that you
didn't finish it and i was i was telling
almost look when i got this rd350 it's a
rolling chassis i got the motor too
and i was supposed to finish it but i
never really got around to it and he's
hemming it on like he might take it
he's got
he's got a bunch of [ __ ] parts in a
trailer to make a rolling chassis he's
got motors too
he wants 1300 from it was 1300 for a
motor and a transmission
so we're going to see what he can do for
me
if i get a harley davidson i'll build it
you know it's not going to be a
trailer queen
i'd rather have that [ __ ] look like a
dirt bike like something out of a
[ __ ] mad max movie i would like a
harley kind of like [ __ ] daryl's
[ __ ] triumph from [ __ ] a walking
dead just real basic
you know
with dirt tires on it something that
could go off-road if it has to
you know that's how i would do it yeah
something harley's are country if you
ask me that's some country redneck [ __ ]
so you you it it should have off-road
capabilities well i always it's funny
because i guess back in the old days
yeah
when bikers were still scary yeah um you
know harley's received as like ooh it
was like this badass kind of thing but
honestly growing up in daytona we had
bike week and all that kind of stuff i
grew to associate harley's with like
middle-aged dudes or older dudes that
were going through their second
childhoods yeah
and had just like you know
dumped their of their first wife
and were either single or had like a
much younger wife and so they decided
they were going to like buy a leather
jacket and some leather chaps and that's
not all of them though no i know but i'm
just saying that that's a lot of the
people that did it yeah a lot of people
that did kept me up i know they're not
all like that obviously because i saw
some actual like real you're right but
you know what i mean it's just kind of
like it got overtaken by posers yeah you
know
it happens in every subculture now the
dude hooking me up is a real thing
and [ __ ] he kind of invited me over
to their little clubhouse he's like but
you can't take any videos over there i
said i'm going to put you on the show i
want to put him on the show
yeah his name is crash
he crashed crash is his name
he's about ten years older than me got a
big [ __ ] i have a cool nickname crash
i don't know what my cool nickname would
be but i just i always wished i had one
crashing his girlfriend
and he's like yeah he's like [ __ ]
there was a there was that like actually
1920s or 1930s cereal that had a
character named crash cory
he was a boxer or wrestler or something
and then he also had superpowers maybe i
don't know i saw someone on mystery
science theater so everybody's showing
up now
maniac says [ __ ] i had a bsa when i was
16 no remember oh i remember a bsa i
even kind of remember those it's a
british bike yeah british small arms
remember those well like i said i lived
in california
and i was into british stuff so it was
kind of like a kind of like a like an
infield
yeah they were good
they were slow though
there were bikes from other era you know
60s 50s and 60s
camp guy said i never had a motorcycle
my mom was super afraid of them i did
ride my son's home at 50 and 70 both
yeah buying a vehicle from a guy who
crashed yeah
[Laughter]
yeah right that's that sounds like well
i didn't know what man i was talking to
for an hour and for about an hour i
thought his name was trash i thought he
said trash
but then his girlfriend goes no it's
crash escaped from the bronx yeah i said
oh okay i thought his name was crash i
thought i'd never trash
yeah or escape 2000 or whatever the [ __ ]
the real name i got a picture obviously
i got a picture of him
i'm gonna show you i'm gonna show you
does he look like a crash
yeah you're gonna see
i have a picture of my head
[Laughter]
we'll see
yeah
gram there's hammer said you'd have some
great stories to tell about jail life
cold food drunks yelling at the walls
dudes whacking off in front of others
yeah yep that's exactly that's correct
that's exactly what i was expecting
that's crash yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
it crashed the bike yeah that's one of
his bikes yeah
no need for me too said i knock myself
uh out off a dirt bike doing a jump as a
team lost a whole day don't ride anymore
yeah yeah
i'm not a bit like for a long time like
tom was trying to like you know teach me
to ride and i run on the back of it a
few times but
yeah like i said i don't even really
like driving a car
so
motorcycle probably not i'm just
it's just too much man i just feel like
yeah i'm just gonna go flying through
[ __ ] space and smash my head like a
pumpkin on the [ __ ] ground no thanks
no thanks not really how i want to go
there's crash's bike
try to see if i can get one his
girlfriend
one of his girlfriends how many he got
no
i want a picture of his girlfriend oh
okay
[Laughter]
yeah
sounds like taking pictures
wait that's not his girlfriend no no no
no no that's great
i'm not judging i'm just i'm just asking
again see what it's nothing to do with
me i'm not i'm not judging other
people's [ __ ] you know what i mean yeah
you could be walking down the street
dressed in a [ __ ] clown costume and
he was funny man they're the big [ __ ]
dude
i'll just be like
whatever i'm sure you have a reason for
that so i'm just like not going to get
involved that's nothing to do with me
so who's in here who's here today
everybody everybody's here look at the
[ __ ] sun coming in the goddamn
windows oh no man it's like some [ __ ]
from [ __ ] well it's it's daylight
savings time now so it's like not dark
even though it's like past six o'clock
i hate it
i hate i hate spring and i hate summer
i'm just gonna have to like hibernate
until fall comes back
i always get it's really weird i know
some people get like depressed and fall
in winter but i get depressed when
spring comes i'm just kind of like the
i don't even i don't even like like all
the
you know you go in the stores and
there's like all the easter [ __ ]
and like all this it's all all the beach
[ __ ] i'm just like oh god damn it why is
this [ __ ] gonna go away
i don't know it bums me out i don't like
it
uh hey our friend david parker is here
hello youtube hey there david what's
going on uh so this is friday night yeah
so you'll probably be going to
mannequins later although weren't they i
think they were doing something at ibar
tonight or barbarella rather oh i think
it's like an industrial night yeah we're
not going to we're not going to
magazines well no no i don't think so i
mean we started this later yeah
but tomorrow night
it's the wind
yeah i'm telling you it's like this
[ __ ]
i don't know what it is i don't know if
it's just like the angle that this room
is at
but there's really like the slightest
wind outside of there and it sounds like
the [ __ ] yeah and it's like creepy
man it sounds like a [ __ ] tornado out
there it sounded like a [ __ ]
wolves [ __ ] howling
what the [ __ ] is that
it's werewolves well that's the corner
of the house i guess so it's just coming
around the corner of the house i guess
that's what it is because i don't think
well it's not like i spend a lot of time
in the other rooms necessarily but
i don't know it's just it's really
really loud
um you were telling me about the jukebox
there yeah
which i'm sure like most jukeboxes are
like this now but you control it through
an app on your phone right yeah it's on
the app and you can talk to the jukebox
and pay through your [ __ ]
uh
right through your atm
your atm card yeah
and it gives you bonuses see
yeah because it wants you to want you to
keep buying buying songs right
so you see you know it's like request
another song will give you a free credit
but each song is usually two credits
unless it's a shitty song it might be
one
but you got anybody metric but they got
everything on there man oh okay so you
can play whatever you want pretty much i
mean so it's not it's not like the old
days were like the old jukeboxes where
they just had like a limited amount no
it's awesome
so if you went in one the last time i
saw it
jukebox yeah was in do you remember when
pizza hut used to be like a big sit-down
restaurant
this was a long time ago like in the 80s
um they used to have a jukebox and i
used to get super excited because i was
just a kid and i used to get super
excited we'd go we'd get a bunch of
pizzas get a pitcher mountain dew
because we're white trash like that and
my mom and dad would give me like a
couple quarters and i could go play some
[ __ ] i'd usually play like duran
duran or something if it was in there
but because we grew up in daytona mostly
it was like rednecky country [ __ ] so but
there was some good [ __ ] in there too
well here it is it this this is the app
it knew what saloon i was in
and then there was even like what's the
most pop yeah it knew what
the most popular songs were
and who played that what are there what
are they uh okay what are the
[ __ ]
okay you see this
okay the hot the hot ones so the staff
picks the hot ones that theo said the
hot songs meaning this is the ones that
most people played a party which is
jimmy buffett oh god leonard skinner
yeah simple man
midland drinking problem meatloaf
paralyzed paradise please by the
dashboard light show this is a biker
music character yeah
journey don't stop believing good lord
yeah
yeah is anybody singing that song again
fat bottom girls
[Laughter]
morgan morgan welling whiskey glasses
brooks and dunn neon moon
jj gray
and mofroe whoever that is
must be a country thing yeah
jamie
johnson high cost of living
little big town
black pumas
merrell hack merle haggard
um
new breed and jesse howard
narls barclays there's a lot of [ __ ]
country yeah a lot of to say
wheeler walker [ __ ] you [ __ ] that's the
name of the [ __ ] song nice i like
that yeah walker hayes
so i was [ __ ] saying [ __ ] that [ __ ]
okay that's what i was playing i was
playing billy idol i played bitter taste
motorhead iron horse born of toulouse i
was playing british biker music
judas priest i played center
uh uh let me see oh look i can see what
they're playing right now
holy [ __ ] i can see what they're playing
right now what's on right now leonard uh
alan jackson oh that's a country okay
yeah and you want me to go hang out at
this place uh well you can play with
what you want i play moderator they
don't want me to play what i want
actually actually the
girls [ __ ] liked what i was playing
especially when i started getting into
[ __ ] new wave
again i don't think yeah
motorhead another perfect day jewish
priest bloodstone white zombie thunder
kiss 65
motorhead sympathy for the devil judas
priest screaming for vengeance
judas priest victim of changes white
zombie i am legend chris isaac wicked
game i played that nice billy idol flesh
for fantasy
deep purple highway star i played that
motorhead's version of heroes their
cover of cover of heroes that's really
nice okay i played alicia keys another
way to die that was [ __ ] the uh oh
okay yeah the frame from uh the bonfire
yeah from the bottom of it okay
uh rolling stones plant but paid it
black motorhead ace of spades
judas priest clique green man alicia i
played that
blondie atomic i played that
well that sounds good yeah
i played okay they started liking this
and girls i played golden earring i
played two gold and rhythm rings so
radar love at twilight zone they like
that they like heart of glass
then i played a couple jimi hendrix
songs are you experienced in machine gun
iron maiden drifter played that play god
smacked whatever
chris cornell know my name another
[ __ ] james bond there you go that's a
good that's a good song actually some
motorhead song called dead men tell no
tales of the bomber album judas priest
devil's child played the cure boys don't
cry they like that one oh okay yeah
and then they they were they were
starting to play with duran duran
okay the girls were playing driving all
right maybe i didn't get along with the
girls then yeah the girls
the girls aren't into the country music
too much they want to hear duran duran
and uh
depeche mode and stuff like that i mean
i'm more down with like i'm down with
like motorhead and [ __ ] like that yeah i
just like rock yeah i don't like that i
don't like that country [ __ ] though yeah
yeah especially like that new country i
don't mind like old old country like i
actually kind of like yeah um
you know like really like hank williams
and you know johnny cash and stuff like
that i like that but all that new
country that kind of came with i don't
like that yeah i don't like that no
country [ __ ] go in there
yeah yeah that's not the biker stuff
i kind of feel like yeah
bikers are more into like some of them
yeah like rock or like southern rock a
lot of them like like hard rocks yeah
like old like classic rock but not
necessarily a country
the most country a lot of those bikers
will go would be like leonard skinner
that's going to be about as country as
they get
from what i've been seeing here
they like rock music they play uh ac dc
yeah see i don't have a problem with
that yeah i'm kind of sick of it because
like i said everywhere i worked they
always played classic rock station yeah
so you know but they'll also do some
[ __ ] like play [ __ ] bob seeger though
too
and see tom will not abide because i
hate that [ __ ]
i started [ __ ] checking out when bob
seger comes on
although bob seger did that song from
beverly hills cop too
yeah that was him i like that one i
totally forgot
but yeah
i mean you know yeah i see everybody's
saying
do you know one time
um i don't know why it occurred to me to
do this did i mention this on the show
before uh you know that bob seeker song
old time rock and roll yeah
i rewrote all of the lyrics
um except they were about pookie
and about how she used to do you
remember back in the old days when we
had the um
the shelves in the bedroom that had like
all the dvds on it and remember if you
weren't feeding her fast enough or
giving her treats she'd get up there and
like start pulling the movies out
throwing them yeah you remember that
yeah uh i wrote like i rewrote old time
rock and roll except it was about that
yeah and i still have the lyrics
somewhere they were actually pretty
[ __ ] funny if i do say so myself
matter of fact i go into my man cave and
i'll find blue rays on the floor yeah so
she's pulling them out in the middle of
the night yeah you get mad in the middle
of night aren't you yeah she gets
frustrated yeah and she just like goes
in there and she's like phone [ __ ] out
yeah ah
yeah
and she flings them yeah we've seen her
do it yeah she does it to my books too
although i've rearranged everything
nowadays so she hasn't really been doing
she still scratches on the on the uh the
spines
sometimes but i knew she did that so i
put like the shittier books on the
bottom shelf
so it's like if she scratches the spines
it's not that big a deal you know like
all my really old ones
but
yeah but it's back when it was over
there she used to like pull the [ __ ] out
all the time if you weren't paying
attention to her she because she knows
we'd yell at her yeah and like come over
there and stop her so hugo's talking
about the johnny be good go cover by
motorhead i remember that one that's
pretty good oh yeah yeah yeah they
actually did they did quite a few covers
i thought
motorhead was good yeah they did a lot
of covers um
lemmy and motorhead were good they were
he denied being metal but come on man
[ __ ] motorhead is metal
it's rock and roll too but
good band
good good bad i kind of feel like
motorhead are one of those bands that
like
everybody kind of likes them you know
what i mean yeah they're one of those
bands that are kind of like just
universally it's like you know there's a
lot of elements in it to get this across
genre right
so people that are into like any kind of
music
it's just kind of like like i said about
johnny cash like even people that aren't
into country music everybody likes
johnny cash yeah
everybody motorhead had a western flavor
to it yeah
it was kind of like metal but it was
also kind of like psychedelic depending
on what album it was um
then they'd do covers
but they were good
i would say it was kind of like it was
especially early on it had biker themes
to it
you know
so it was kind of like british biker
mood music but not rocker music if some
of you guys don't know what rocker is
but
it was kind of like fake biker music
in a way
john gorra says they were on the young
ones i remember that episode they did uh
ace of spades
what episode was that though um
they didn't make that many they only
made like 11 or 12 episodes i used to
have them all on tape but i can't
remember which one motorhead here's the
funny thing about [ __ ] lemmy
let me kill mr the singer from motorhead
he was kind of like the brains behind it
he did a whole [ __ ] career
with really good rock music and had some
fantastic albums
but more than half of his wealth
actually came from one song
and it was kind of like the residuals
from a song he wrote for ozzy osbourne
called mama i'm coming home remember
that one yep lenny wrote that song yeah
and
the residuals from that song [ __ ]
actually
made him most of his money more than
half the money from all those other
albums that he wrote ridiculous what do
you think about it
i mean because this is kind of a generic
song but
that song made him a lot of money
yeah he probably didn't cry about it
he's just kind of like oh well no
then he wrote that [ __ ] that
kind of a motorhead song it's a
motorhead song with that ozzy singing
john smith said oh that was the bambi
episode that's right when they go on
university challenge actually one of
honestly they were all good but i think
bambi was probably my favorite one
but nasty was good too that had the
damned on it but uh that was when they
rented them
they rented a vcr and they rented a
a video nasty yeah and then there was a
vampire in their bathroom so
[Laughter]
libby was a good man
i mean you know he was kind of shy
wrote real good music
his his friend [ __ ] phil taylor also
known as filthy animal taylor would sit
there and [ __ ] drive him and just
[ __ ]
just drive him over stealing his
girlfriends and [ __ ] there's some those
jenny and i watched the damn
show remember that when they were on
there yeah and phil taylor was sitting
there just
[ __ ] just
dragging on him poor [ __ ]
lemmy
so it's funny
but um
weird thing about lambie is there's not
weird thing about let me read you say
it's a good thing about lambie
is that um
he didn't he had a son and he didn't
know it he found out later
that he had a son
and it was
some girl that they were hanging out the
band was hanging out with for a while
he had a a son with her
and
later on he got to know the guy
once he was
you know older
you know he was in i think he was in his
late 20s when he met when he met his son
you know the son was in his late
twenties
and it was funny because like uh
lemmy was towards the end of his life at
that time
and he become friends with this
his son
and he said all this stuff that i built
you know all this [ __ ] music that i
wrote there's really nothing you know
he's like [ __ ] he goes this is the
best thing i ever did and he second
point at this guy which kind of [ __ ]
was touching when you think about it
a lot of people say that about their
kids making this guy was the best thing
i ever did
yeah and he didn't know his son until
later yeah yeah i wonder if he regretted
that
what's that
not no not knowing about it earlier
wasn't his choice
i mean
it probably happened a lot the thing
about it is that well a lot of times
like even if you have some like a you
know fling with some dude and then like
you don't find out you're pregnant until
like weeks and weeks later and you might
not even talk to that dude anymore yeah
and then you're just kind of like well
the girl the girl didn't tell him
evidently yeah
you know well it doesn't happen i mean
she was one of those girls i think that
just wanted to have a [ __ ]
kid from a rock star that she was
you know that she was like a fan of i
think it was like that
you know yeah it could be although
sometimes too it's like if you just had
like a one-night stand or something like
that you're just like well i don't want
to bother the person uh no no it wasn't
a one-night thing [ __ ] um oh okay
yeah no i'm just saying like you know in
general it wasn't a one night thing uh
based on what i remember from what lemmy
said he knew who she was she was around
in the scene for a long time okay he
didn't know that she had gotten pregnant
he didn't know that she got pregnant
from him though and then later on when
he was growing he found out that that
was his son yeah
and um
it was and he said that was the best
thing he ever did that was it was funny
because they were like friends yeah you
know they were like talking about lenny
was big into like uh world war ii and
world war one
weapons and like you know airplanes and
tanks and guns and history
he was big into
early
1900s or you know 20th century
uh warfare stuff and so was so was his
son i guess it's like genetic they were
like big into that [ __ ]
yeah i mean interests do ten not always
but
people tend to be interested in the same
kind of things as like their
matter i think i think lemmy actually
bought a [ __ ] attack a world war ii
attack i mean why wouldn't you yeah i
think he had three
had it or rented one because he was
riding around on one
he could try he was driving what around
ali asked did pookie finish all of her
tuna sticks because ali was the one that
sent that big box it's only halfway
through him um yeah well because i
ordered i ordered some too and then like
earlier and then they came so we have
like a whole drawer full of them she
does try to get all of them though she
tries to she's been eating like two or
three of them a day we're trying to
ration them she'll ask for them even
when she's not gonna eat them all
yes i have to shut her off and uh
last night it must have been a [ __ ]
one or two in the morning i heard
something i woke up i had i had my
earphones in
and she's there by the by the uh the
side of the bed
standing in front
yeah cause i keep in my dresser she's
standing in front of the dresser and she
[ __ ] gets up and smacks a dresser
like open that [ __ ] up that's where they
are and i'm like no
yeah she does this thing she's like
no and her little butt wiggles
she got mad and walked away
then she runs out the rim yeah yeah
[ __ ] you it was too late
there's a circle i didn't know she
started doing that in the middle of the
night yeah she tried yeah she tried the
middle of the night like two o'clock
because she's usually like
we're usually like on a schedule like i
said like we'll be
like seven eight o'clock at night
everyone's kind of like you know
finished work for the day and then we're
kind of like settling in like watch a
movie or whatever and then as soon as
she knows that as soon as mommy and
daddy are both in the room like watching
something then it's time to come in and
ask for one so she'll like toddle into
the room and then she sits over there by
the nightstand where the drawer is and
then she'll just stare
and if you don't look at her she'll go
like hey
or she'll trill and then you turn around
and you're like oh okay and then you
give her one and then you have to we
told her you have to hold it yeah you
can't just put it on the ground
you have to hold it and then she'll lick
it for a while so you have to like be
ready to like commit and like sit there
and like hold it for her to like
lick it and then she'll chew on it
and then there's like it gets down to a
little piece because you don't want to
hold it like that because she'll like
bite your fingers
and then like you drop it on the floor
and then she gets all pissed off like
what the [ __ ]
you ruined it yeah you ruined it john
smith says [ __ ] yeah
they asked lim if he was a nazi for
wearing all that memorabilia he says if
the israeli army had cooler stuff i'd be
collecting that well another thing that
[ __ ] went
lemme [ __ ] dated black porn stars
that was another thing
his girlfriend was mocha
and uh
he had that german tank and uh he had a
bunch of german stuff world war one and
world war ii and he's like they're
asking me about my nazis like uh if i'm
a nazi i'm the only nazi that's [ __ ]
in the black girls
[Laughter]
he wasn't he was just like cool looking
stuff that's all it was and the germans
had real cool looking stuff everybody
agrees on that
yeah they did it's it's it's a shame
that they yeah they had real cool
monstrous in other ways but yeah well
they spent the money they did have cool
looks they had real cool looking stuff
they they knew they understood branding
yeah for sure
uh jason says hey foodies what are your
favorite brands of peanut butter
[Laughter]
well here in the united states most of
the peanut butter brands are about the
same
yeah i never really took honestly um i
never really noticed that much of a
difference between oh you know what he'd
hear something peanut butter adjacent
you had bought
a long time ago
that mix of like peanut butter and jelly
in the same jar which were great the
goober grape yeah which like you said
when you were a kid that was like
terrible because they hadn't figured out
how to like get the textures right for
both things like in one jar yeah but you
had it the other day and we just kind of
like whipped up a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich because you know we
didn't feel like you didn't feel like
making anything yeah and that was
actually pretty decent it was great
so i guess they figured out whatever
issues they had back in the old days
smucker's goober grape
it's got stripes it's [ __ ] peanut
butter and grape jelly and stripes i
mean we have regular peanut butters here
we just had that from i don't even
remember when we got that that was a
long and um
yeah i kept it and i i'm halfway through
the jar that [ __ ] was [ __ ] good
so then i went down to um
got halfway through that and i went over
here to um
dollar general store and they had their
own store brand of it that came in a
plastic jar
which had been more like something we
would have carried in the army because
it's not you know because it's not glass
jar it's it's plastic is not breakable
you know
the smuckers was in a glass jar we
couldn't have carried that in the army
so i but i haven't gotten on to the
[ __ ] uh dollar general stuff yet
i'm hoping it tastes the same
if it tastes the same then that means if
you're a backpack and you don't have to
carry two jars you carry one jar see
efficient it's a fish
[Laughter]
honestly if you toast the bread and put
a bunch of butter on it and then put
that on it
it'll probably taste fine you can't
you can't spread it with a [ __ ] knife
though you need because you can't get
enough of it up
it's got to be a spoon
you get your big spoon
and you go around and you get it all
there and you spread it out that way
it's good real good
yeah there are two different flavors
wait wait wait wait peanut butter peanut
butter and strawberry peanut butter and
strawberry or peanut butter peanut
butter actually one or two that might be
good actually grape or strawberry
because honestly um i mean strawberry
jam is really good too yeah it's good i
like green peanut butter i do too but
they're both good yeah
honestly if i'm just gonna have
jam on toast i'd rather have strawberry
but yeah
okay so how long we've been streaming uh
41 minutes okay now it's about the time
to start [ __ ]
everybody's here 24. well start doing
what this is okay sidetrack show that's
right just saying strawdog 78 said
remember that guy that built a homemade
tank and wanted a rampage in a small
town yeah yeah we did they made a uh
yeah they made a documentary about that
guy called tread
yeah was it just called tread or treads
i think so we do might be on netflix
yeah so we did actually talk about i
don't know if we did like a regular show
but we talked about that
uh documentary so we talked about that
case yeah but uh yeah that guy was kind
of late right alex says i once met a
lady who said her name was moni and that
after meeting billy idol he wrote the
song about her lol shh i don't think she
realized he remade it yeah that's a
cover yeah it's a cover so
[Laughter]
and he actually named it after m-o-n-y
or whoever wrote it
named it after uh they were looking out
their window in new york and it was
what was it mutual of omaha of new york
or something like that it was like an
acronym and they said oh that'd be a
good name for a song that's with how the
story goes anyway i don't know if that's
true um
yeah what i was saying is i was saying
that
this is friday it's open lines type
friday so if you guys have any questions
on anything any cases that we did in the
past
any kind of uh paranormal or unsolved
mysteries you can go ahead and drop them
down the comment section we'll talk
about we'll talk about
um but uh other than that we will just
sit here and [ __ ] [ __ ] and drink
um which is that's what's fun that's
what we like to do yeah it's friday
night
jason says
we call it jam in the uk well there's a
difference though between i mean i think
most people know that jelly in the
united states because in the uk it's
jell-o right wait a minute no
that's not what it means no in the in
the uk right what they call jelly is
what we call jello right okay gelatin
like jello the dessert right
um
but over here
jelly and jam are similar
but they're not the same i kind of well
jelly
is more
fruit juice
pectin pectin yeah and
made into like whereas jam is more like
actual
preserves are like fruit like smushed up
you're right
but yeah jelly is more like a
because i've made it i made it in uh
home eq before
it's grape juice and pectin and one
other thing
cream of tartar i want to say jelly is
like
it's like um
uh
jelly is like preserves or jam it's like
that just that doesn't have whole fruit
in it
it's just the juice of the fruit
turned into that
but it has nothing to do with jello
jello is gelatin
that's actually i think it's [ __ ]
coming from horse hoves right or um cow
hooves it's it does i don't know if it
does anymore it did it but it used to
yeah they made it out of hooves right
and that has to be served cold and it's
usually like something you'd make aspect
out of or if it'd be fruit flavored and
that [ __ ]
whipped cream on it you know it's
totally different
suspend some pineapples in that [ __ ]
you know
jelly's a lot better than jello a lot
better
i remember you know what they um one
thing that was all the rage in the 70s
and early 80s i feel like and my mom and
grandma used to make it
was this
jello cake but you didn't make it into
like the jello because jello comes in
like a little box and it's like powder
right and then you mix it with water and
you have to like refrigerate it like as
it jellos out
but there was this cake that you made
and it was
lemon i want to say and then like you
injected
either lemon
jello like liquid form or green jello
and you injected it down into the cake
and then you baked it so then when you
cooked it it had like these kind of like
stripes of like green or yellow like
jello in there our girl tila just showed
up what's up t hey what's up yeah jelly
is good for your nails yeah cause like i
said it's made of hooves i don't know if
they make it from hooves anymore yeah
but that's what it was made of that's
why it was such a big deal
um because you know in case people
wonder like in mid-century like why the
[ __ ] were they suspending everything in
jell-o for christ's sake yeah tea jam is
thicker and it has actual fruit pulp in
it yeah it's me it's got fruit in it
jelly is just it jelly does too but it's
just the juice it's just juice yeah it's
juice and like pectin so it's like a
waxy you can take grape juice and turn
that into jelly
you can take apple juice and turn that
into gel yeah
you know it doesn't have any fruit
fiber in it right
okay
uh
t says they just re-watched the tent
last night haven't seen a long-time
movie so good yeah it's a [ __ ]
freaky-ass flick goddamn i love that
real freaky
i mean there's so many psycho drama the
first time that i saw that movie like
when he found that hole in the wall and
then like he was digging around in there
and then like found a [ __ ] tooth in
there i was like ugh
goes into the bed
goes into the bathroom and sees himself
in the other building oh that freaked me
out so bad [ __ ] like that like i don't
know why but like that whole
doppelganger thing if i see that because
david lynch does it a lot
and it's like if i see that in a movie
that just like wigs me right the [ __ ]
out and i don't know why i'm still
trying to like you recommended that
movie we did a show on it a long time
ago and then had a comment in the bottom
of the video that we did and says oh
well [ __ ] this movie was the [ __ ]
biggest waste of time thank you for
[ __ ] wasting
two hours of my life and i'm like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
it's a [ __ ] weird ass movie man
i guess it maybe didn't translate across
generations i don't know but
well the thing about it is
with the [ __ ] of perv all right
that [ __ ] is a perv yeah no
one's defending roman police but his
that movie was weird man but i do love
that movie i mean he made some [ __ ]
great ass movies yeah i mean even though
he's kind of a [ __ ] but he made some
awesome movies well that's the thing
that's why
see there's enough that's another thing
i don't understand like i'm not
necessarily like recommending the movie
i'm just saying we like that movie so we
were talking about it creepy flint and
i don't understand like if you took our
advice and watched it or you you know
got interested to watch it and then you
don't like it like don't [ __ ] blame
me for that [ __ ] i didn't make the movie
piss off right you know what i mean
camp guy says he's yelling at me for cam
guy says we have about 60 jars of jelly
canned from two summers of gathering
muscadines grapes and blackberries we'll
never have to buy it in the grocery with
the rest of yeah yeah well you could
just take [ __ ] fruit juice and make a
lot of jelly
yeah
one that i want to do is something my my
grandmother used to make something
called apple butter
mmm i gotta figure out how to make that
honestly i like pretty much apple
anything like apple fritters
ooh we should make some apple fritters
yeah let's do that now they're in there
fighting over billy idol that his best
was dancing with myself another guy says
no house without a face no actually look
i'm
[ __ ] grew up with billy idol saw him
live
billy idol's best album was [ __ ]
whiplash smile
it was which is not really one of his
fav one of his most famous ones but
[ __ ] a world's forgotten boy was a
[ __ ] good song that whole album was
really good it was it was almost metal
it was the one that had uh
don't need a gun on it even though
that's not a that's a good song but it's
not one of his best
the all the b-side stuff that was on
whiplash smile was really good
i think that was his best album
um well you know i i don't really know
enough about it because i haven't heard
all of his stuff but
oracle says the stripe it rich cake
that's exactly what it was i can't
believe you remember what that was
called yeah that was like all the
[ __ ] rage and any time that you went
to like a dinner party like in the 70s
or 80s or you went to like a potluck and
somebody was bringing desserts
inevitably someone would bring
that with like the stripes of
jello
camp guy points out when you cook a
whole chicken you will get a lot of
jello out of the drippings skim the fat
and gelatin is left yeah you can do that
same with ham and beef yeah so you can
make and so that's why people think it's
weird that's like why was that why was
every [ __ ] like suspending [ __ ]
in jello in the 1950s and onward that's
because it's a variation of
aspic which was made from
you know kind of like gelatin to fat
from like meat and stuff and they would
suspend stuff in that and it was like
really really hard to make and really
time consuming so the fact that now you
could make it
really quickly like instant uh was a big
deal so everybody felt super fancy and
rich
because before that aspect was something
that only rich people
had
because it was really time consuming to
make when you had to
when you had to make everything from
scratch you know what i mean like they
didn't have all these like convenience
foods yeah uh john gorra says bitter
moon with peter coyote was cool [ __ ] i
hadn't thought about that movie in a
long time i remember seeing that several
times back in the old days and that was
really good strong 78 says david lynch
got his creepy doppelganger thing from
baba's kill baby kill yeah
honestly i have killed baby kill on dvd
somewhere and i need to i think it's in
the other room i need to review that one
of these days so
i gotta i'm so behind on movies you guys
i'm just i'm trying to like catch up
i'm so behind
and i got a message today it's like are
you gonna do um jack's back with uh
james spader and i was like holy [ __ ]
that's like really weird because i
actually was gonna do that like a couple
months ago and then like
it got knocked off the schedule so now
i'm gonna have to do it in april
sometime because i told him i would do
it next month
tina's going on about
be the idol that's the album that you
need to that that was his best album
whiplash smile
you want to check that one out
it was uh
it had it was just
a it was kind of a harder album
it still had a pop
kind of vibe to it but it was
it was slicker
more metallic sounding you just have to
listen to it to understand what i'm
talking about i liked it better
jason says applesauce and roast pork
with stuffing yeah yeah honestly apple
and pork is like a beautiful combination
yeah one of my favorite things when i
was in the uk was to get um a pork and
apple
uh pasty
oh those were so good god damn those
were good
but yeah i got those a lot of times look
at the way look at the way billy used to
look that was
1986 or seven i think
that shirt remember that shirt jenny
yeah
yeah i knew a couple people that had
that shirt the [ __ ] was gothic [ __ ]
yeah
that was very that was very uh
yeah that was the area of the time like
you could
remember like i knew there were some
models in propaganda that were wearing
wearing that shirt that had those like
blades on them like that daggers yeah
and like uh
there's pants that had that on it yeah
that was very of the moment yeah
um camp guy says i like the novelty
halloween cake that's like a kitty
litter box with the cake inside and the
melted tootsie rolls yeah that's uh yeah
the litter box cake and this it's funny
because i think i brought that up on
some other show and you didn't believe
me that that was like a real thing
what's that the litter box cake yeah you
haven't seen the litter box cake it's a
cake but you put like on the top you put
like this crumbly kind of stuff so it
looks like litter it looks like sand and
then you melt tootsie rolls and like put
them in there like little cat turds yeah
you know what i mean so for halloween
tea goes man he looks so young on album
cover
look man
get that web last shot that whiplash
smile album and listen to that it'll
make a lot more sense because he was
really coming into his own at that time
but it was after white wedding and rebel
yell and all that he was
probably uh late 20s it was just
he was becoming a young man in in iraq
living out in california and he was part
punk rock part metal part goth
had a death rock kind of a
vibe to it steve stevens who is
guitarist was just [ __ ] at the top of
his game that was just
a great album
it was not a commercial
great
but artistically it was a great album
that was his best album one of his best
albums all of his albums were good he
didn't put out anything inferior they
were all good
it took him a long time to put out an
album
he wasn't these guys that would put out
an album every year
it might take five or six album years
for him to put out an album
he was in he had his contract didn't
force him
to put out a bunch of [ __ ]
because that'll kill you too making too
many goddamn albums all right so all of
his stuff is good but that whiplash
smile album was [ __ ]
that was his best album if he asked me
artistically
jason says would you guys review films
by specific actors or directors like a
series of reviews i feel like we've done
that a little bit um
oracle says yeah like the burt reynolds
series we've been doing which we didn't
like actually mean to do that we did
like a mini burt reynolds series and
like a mini charles bronson series just
because we watched one and they were
like oh let's watch this other one but
i've thought about doing that i actually
wanted to do like a series of david
lynch because i think all i've done is
mulholland drive and maybe lost highway
but i kind of wanted to do like a whole
series of that i want to do a whole
dario argento one i have reviewed some
dario argento movies we did suspiria i
did phenomena i just recorded a review
for trauma from 1993
and i think i did opera as well like a
little while ago but i kind of wanted to
do like all his movies at some point i
think we did deep red too didn't we not
i think we did deep breaths yeah
but uh yeah mr anita says
billy idol was the first choice for the
t-1000 in terminator 2.
i think he had his motorcycle accident
around that time which prevented him
doing it how awesome would that have
been
pretty good it had been pretty good i
mean that movie would have been better
if that [ __ ] kid wasn't in it yeah
and hit billy
and had billy idol in it yeah they could
still have a kid in it just not an
annoying 90s right
because i kind of feel like that was a
whole
that was a whole thing tila says mother
of tears okay
now
i'm gonna have to rewatch that because
i remember seeing it
i didn't see it in the theater because
it didn't play over here or it didn't
play in the city where i was
and
i bought it on dvd as soon as it came
out because i was like the third one in
the three mothers trilogy hooray it's
like taking so long
and i remember watching it and being
like
what the [ __ ] i really didn't like it
but i haven't watched it since then
so i don't know
i'd have to like watch it again to see
because i kind of feel like it's weird
because
and uh i just recorded a review today
it's not going up until uh
uh april 2nd i think but i recorded a
review for trauma which came out of 1993
and i saw that maybe like a [ __ ] ton of
times like back in the 90s but i hadn't
like watched it a long time and then
shutter put it up and i watched it and i
was like oh yeah i kind of remember this
movie it's not great but because a lot
of his stuff after opera wasn't so
fantastic
but there was a lot of stuff in it that
i liked i remember really not liking
mother of tears but that might have been
because i was expecting it to be like
suspiria and inferno and i was really
pissed that it wasn't so
i will eventually get around to doing it
though because i want to re-watch it
because i remember hating it i didn't
hate it but i just didn't love it
i forgot to ask tila something taylor
did you did you
she put it said she put it on her list
did you listen to bananarama
all right that's the first thing did you
listen to bananarama and then did you
see um golden child
and [ __ ]
what was the other one that [ __ ] uh
uh vampire in brooklyn
because yeah
we reviewed that didn't we we didn't do
vampire in brooklyn i thought we did
well
no i don't think we did we need to see
we mentioned it but i don't think we did
a show on it
we got to do a show on vampire and
brooklyn i thought we did a matinee on
that i'll have to look back okay we've
done like so many movies i can't even
remember like what ones you've done we
did blacula one and two
yeah i remember that we did them both on
the same show actually yeah that was a
long time ago vampire in brooklyn
actually was almost kind of like a
black of the spin-off there was a lot in
common with that
and i know there's a bunch of movies
that eddie needs to [ __ ] finish up he
needs to finish up
um beverly hills cop
he needs to finish up
[ __ ] i i think he i think he ought to
do a part two of [ __ ] vampire
brooklyn if you ask me
oh or do a part three of [ __ ] blacula
imagine if eddie murphy did blacula
part three yeah that could work yeah i
think it'd be really good i could see it
i just see him
i think he'd make a good mama waldy he'd
have to really become super gravitas
but his age
he he's older now
you know
and [ __ ] oh what's his name who
[ __ ] what's that actor's name who did
mama walden
[ __ ]
william william uh
yeah that dude they said no [ __ ] i
mean that guy was a [ __ ] he was a
heavy you know i mean he'd really have
to uh
get his [ __ ] gravitas going but i
could see i could
on the back of a vampire in brooklyn i
could see eddie murphy doing mamawaldi
at his age now yeah i can see that yeah
it'd be good i wouldn't mind him i
wouldn't mind
to see
[ __ ] eddie murphy [ __ ]
revisit the [ __ ] golden child
[Laughter]
imagine that
i mean that would be really reaching
you'd really have to [ __ ] write a
badass yeah i'm not really sure where
they could go with how you yeah that had
the same character come back
and do something you could do it i mean
it wouldn't be well anything's possible
yeah you have good writing anything is
possible
tila said yeah i listened to
bananarama's cruel summer and venus i
really like cruel summer a lot out of
all my places yeah venus is a cover
though but yeah
uh tila says if morgan freeman was
younger he could do a good blacula yeah
that would have been good yeah
um
oh wait i saw something else she also
said both suspirias are great yeah i
agree uh mother of tears was most
disappointing like i said i remember
being like really bummed out that it
wasn't like the other ones and it seemed
to not have not had that much like
continuity with it and that kind of like
made me angry yeah um
lars elric recommends belle de jour
which i've seen like several times uh
and that is a fantastic fantastic movie
i think
i [ __ ] i feel like i have that on dvd
somewhere
maybe it's i don't know i have like
piles of dvds that i don't know but yeah
i'm i'm sure i've i have that someplace
taylor when you get a chance go see
bananarama's [ __ ]
robert de niro's waiting that's another
good video
there's a video to that
uh that's a good song it's
this is old school girl band [ __ ]
british new wave girl band
i mean that was [ __ ] almost on par
with [ __ ]
menudo
[Laughter]
but now let's not sit let's not do that
i mean
we're not really i never got into
maneuvers what made bananarama legit is
that they actually did their own little
dance steps and they wrote their own
little songs and yeah they had some
people help them out later on but they
were
uh kind of self-made in the early days
they were just
uh three british girls from nowhere
really in england and came up a little
band
now
the one girl
siobhan fahey her sister
was the girl from uh the dexy's midnight
runners
come on eileen video that's that's
siobhan's little sister would i run a
bathroom i don't know if you've ever
seen that video but dixie's midnight
runners had a
real famous song called come on eileen
it was kind of a little irish jig
and uh
they got this [ __ ] randy [ __ ]
trying to get laid
off this little
blonde in her [ __ ]
coveralls
well that little blonde is um
um siobhan siobhan fahey's sister little
sister
from bananarama
uh siobhan is a little shorter
blonde
in bananarama
she was also that same girl later on
ended up being um in a band called
shakespeare's sister which is a real
good band
um
they're still around
to this day actually i think they live
out in la they just came out with a new
album a couple years back
where it was funny because like in the
video they had drag queens impersonating
them it was kind of funny they were
fighting their own drag queens
but uh i liked all those bands
yeah it's called come on eileen
yeah
come on eileen oh i swear
yeah you'll know you'll know the song
i thought everybody knew coming
everybody she's like it's called come on
the name of that song
if you go over right now
open another window and just [ __ ] go
come on eileen that song's got a [ __ ]
like 30 million views
all right
that song has been around forever you'll
you'll probably recognize it
but that girl in that video is siobhan
fahi's little sister
john smith said the song come on eileen
made life hell for any girl called
eileen you're gonna try to come on her
well yeah yeah well honestly it's the
same i mean because my name is jenny and
in the 80s everybody's like oh is your
phone number eight six seven five 309.
like i haven't heard that one before
holy [ __ ] i've had that one like
recently
i was buying some food the other day and
they said what my name was so they could
call my name when my food was ready yes
it has
and they asked me that she's listening
to it now yeah it has violin in it is
talking about that's a fiddle come on
johnny ray
what is this
something right
did a million hearts in mono
yeah yeah it's talking about [ __ ]
i don't remember all the lyrics just
talking about obviously talking about
johnny ray was singing to our parents
and now he's gone and now now it's a new
time and we got johnny ray was that
singer from the 50s yeah that had the
ear uh the uh the hearing aid that's
where morrissey got the idea back in the
80s to put the hearing aided from johnny
the idea is is that our parents time is
over this is singing from the point of
view of the 80s our parents time up here
in the hockey motherland is over let's
get the [ __ ] out of here all right let's
[ __ ] move to [ __ ] london that's
what they're talking about in our
overall in our overalls
let's leave we're leaving ireland and
we're going to london
yes
john goris brings up romeo void yeah i
remember them yeah they did that uh
might like you better slept together
yeah
never say never uh the name of that
which still gets played at uh
independent bar slash barbarella pretty
much every saturday or every other
saturday probably but yeah they still
play that
um let's say john smith said i thought
shakespeare's sister broke up because
they couldn't stand each other maybe no
they're back together are they yeah they
might have broken up but they're back
together they just put out a new album
not even a year ago huh it's good yeah
tila says lol yes they all got overalls
yeah yeah
and it just it's a country song
it's like up in ireland and [ __ ] [ __ ]
in the country they got coveralls and
they don't have no [ __ ] socks on and
some of them don't have shirts on them
they don't have shirts overalls either
we just have overalls that randy it's
all one
one piece you know that horny
[ __ ] is trying to [ __ ] knock
that girl up right in the middle of the
street
and she's like nah get the [ __ ] away
from me you hairy curly-haired [ __ ]
yeah
starbucks 78 remember the song mickey
i was totally i was into that song
that's about what like 81 oh he's
talking about uh what's her name tony
basil yeah and tony basil is like close
to [ __ ] 80 and she's [ __ ] cute as
[ __ ]
well that was like her one well she was
a choreographer she actually like
choreographed like a lot of videos and
movies and [ __ ] like that in the 80s so
that kind of like one-off was her that
was her big like one-hit wonder but that
wasn't really her actual job she just
kind of like tony basil and her dad was
[ __ ] oh what's his name and if
[ __ ] he was he was what was that
guy's name he was from um
uh uh
what was i got his name
tony curtis right wasn't that her dad
oh was it i think it might have been her
dad i'd have to look that up i'm not
entirely sure think about her dad i'm
not
yeah
she's like 70 something and uh she's
sucking one of these uh
girls that [ __ ] stand on top of her
hormone regiments and she looks great
i'm gonna tell you a [ __ ] um
she can dance like crazy too
let me see if i can get a video yeah
that was like her whole like i said she
was a dancer and choreographer yeah more
than she was a pop star that like i said
that was just kind of like a one-off and
i remember in the 80s every [ __ ]
cheerleading squad in america
had a routine to that [ __ ] song
during that
that mickey's song she was in her 40s a
lot of people don't realize that yeah
because she was yeah she was so dead
because like i said she had a career
prior to that yeah before if she was a
pop star
she like had other [ __ ] going on that's
that's tony at 73.
okay
look at her go
the girls know joe
73
all right you said well it's not a big
deal she's [ __ ] 73
a lot of people at 73 are in the [ __ ]
old folks home they can barely walk
all right
and she's still got a cute face
okay
john smith said i remember seeing her
being interviewed about that song and
saying she'd made only around 2 500 out
of it because she did not write it or
the music yeah probably right that sucks
she got famous off of it though
yeah that's true
yeah i mean you know hopefully
yeah yeah tony curtis that's jamie lee
curtis's
uh okay yeah yeah so that's probably
what you were thinking that's who i was
thinking of i thought her fat i thought
her dad was famous
i thought i don't know well you have a
you have a computer right there right
here you can look it up i thought tony
basil's dad was from
hold on let me see she should make a
movie with jackie chan
i would watch it not gonna lie not gonna
lie
man i should go get another drink i'll
get you one oh okay hold on
let me see but you have to look at that
if her dad's away okay
well
first of all
let's see tony when she was a kid
back in the 60s all right so we're
already talking about fantastic genetics
okay i mean she was cute all right let's
see what she look like a 73
in her 70s
still cute
you know for 70s that's a pretty
fantastic hat yeah
yeah
and um
john smith says she's also one of the
girls in the lsd new orleans graveyard
scene an easy rider and that was her 40s
in her 40s yeah
so you know
i just remember everybody doing that
right everybody doing a cheerleader i
thought her dad
but let me see
well like i said you probably i'm
looking right now wikipedia page or
something like that
no she wasn't okay i got i got her
[ __ ] confused with somebody else
i mean it's not like a lot of people
don't have like famous parents right i
thought she had famous parents nope
good
but i remember i just remember her being
uh like a choreographer like a dancer
and a choreographer that was like her
main thing yeah and then she was kind of
like because i kind of feel like in the
80s there was like a lot of one-hit
wonder type situations which maybe there
was in the 90s and [ __ ] too i don't know
i don't follow it as much
but
some of that was
kind of manufactured i guess it was
somebody that wasn't really a pop star
and they were just kind of like fronting
for
some other [ __ ] but um t if you don't
know who that is go look at [ __ ] tony
basil mickey
you'll immediately recognize that song
probably make it yeah i kind of feel
like that song is like [ __ ]
ubiquitous and
was it covered i feel like so maybe
somebody covered it
i don't know maybe they didn't
i feel like somebody covered like every
single [ __ ]
one hit wonder song from the [ __ ] 80s
you know a starry night did a cover of
uh voices carry that till tuesday song
it's actually pretty fantastic
it's funny because
uh
michael the lead singer
who is only like in his early 30s
so he said that uh that either the other
band members or
their uh their label had said oh you
need to cover like an 80s song and they
recommended that he do voices carry and
he didn't know that song
and uh so it was kind of funny that he
was just kind of like i don't know if i
wanna do that one or not it's like i
don't even know that song it's just like
really funny it's like you guys are so
[ __ ] young holy crap well i mean he
is like some of the others aren't but
yeah it's hilarious uh yeah oh and yeah
mr 88 points out paula abdul was a
prolific choreographer before she was
pop star yeah same thing
[Music]
i gotta go um and get the water i forgot
to bring the water up oh you know we
don't have any water no i filled it up
but i didn't bring it up oh well you
were taking a bunch of garbage and [ __ ]
down too at the same time
john gore says speaking of easy rider
graveyard girls karen black is great in
the druggie film born to win you know
what i don't think i've ever seen that
i need to see more karen black stuff
honestly i've seen a lot of stuff with
her in it she was in a [ __ ] ton of stuff
but
i think i've said before but one of my
favorite things of hers
that she was in was i mean other than
the obvious ones like burnt offerings
and stuff and trilogy of terror
was a movie called
uh what's it called the strange
possession of mrs oliver i think it was
a tv movie and i think it's free on
youtube or at least it was like when i
watched it which was a while back but i
don't know i really really dug that one
and she was in that too
um
yeah paulie used to choreograph janet
jackson yeah so
that's kind of the thing if you're like
in if you're in there and you could
dance like i said i kind of feel like in
the 80s and 90s that was kind of like a
big
thing if you could do like these dance
moves and [ __ ] like that
um
yeah tila said i only know karen black
from burnt offerings and that troll doll
running after this beer
yeah so trilogy of terror and bird top
rings i mean those were well she was in
the rob zombie uh she was in house for a
thousand corpses too
and but she was in a [ __ ] ton of stuff
karen black was yeah my dad loved that
woman
well we've said that before she there's
something got like kind of sexy about
her she's kind of funny looking but like
in a in a hot sort of way you know what
i'm saying
but yeah strange possession of mrs
oliver i saw that just randomly
um on youtube one day just because she
was in it i was like oh karen black is
in it so i watched it and i was like wow
that was really good
it was like a really weird
and it was like a really weird thriller
that like i totally did like took a
bunch of twists that i totally did not
see coming i think it was late 70s i
want to say it was 78 77 78 something
like that but uh yeah it's really good i
really liked it a lot
tila says i need to re-watch house of a
thousand corpses i remember being good
though i'm not a zombie fan yeah i saw
it in the theater and i remember really
liking it um but i haven't seen it in a
long time
i think it's on
to be
for free it might be
i just remember well i remember that one
being kind of fun
like kind of [ __ ] up but also like fun
i feel like
like devil's rejects and three from hell
i think they kind of got to a point
where they were still good but i he was
just getting like more and more
mean-spirited or he was just kind of
like getting to a point where let's see
how [ __ ] up i can make this
whereas the first one still was kind of
fun you know what i mean the other ones
were not really all that fun
they were just kind of like [ __ ] up
um she said she kind of liked lords of
salem you know i haven't watched lords
of salem yet that's one of the newer
ones
yeah i mean it's fairly new um
but
i don't know i kept hearing like mixed
reviews about it and i said i'll get
around to it one of these days but i
just haven't yet
i like rob zombie
sort of like i like his movies sort of
um i have to be in the mood for him i
like his music a lot but
i don't know and like i said i really
got mad at him after that whole like
halloween debacle
debacle
i was saying he did he did what he
didn't know it just made me so angry
look i know i'm not like questioning his
horror credentials i know he's into
horror [ __ ] i just really wish that
i don't know it just i kind of feel like
sometimes
you get to a point where you it's just a
little too edge lordy for me that's all
it's just too
i don't know he's saying that she
doesn't mind saying that the 70s and 80s
music was actually kind of like the best
um
the thing with the 70s and 80s music is
that it had a
certain amount of personality to it it
was kind of like a little bit more
intimate in a certain way
it was like they were talking to you
when they're singing
they're kind of private moments and
private thoughts it wasn't
it was kind of like music from that era
was made to be listened to amongst
friends it wasn't really
it didn't seem to be written for mass
market it wasn't commercial
a lot of it some of it was but a lot of
it wasn't
um and a lot of the great songs from the
time like for instance like
you know uh [ __ ] come on eileen
that's a song that's
kind of sung between friends in a way
that and they're talking about things
that outsiders wouldn't understand
you have to know the background of the
song to know what they're talking about
well one of the best things i think
about a lot of the new wave kind of
stuff that came out and why people still
remember those songs fondly
when they maybe don't remember some of
the more mainstream like pop songs from
the 80s as much
is because when you had new wave that
was like came in the wake of punk where
everything was opened up so
you could like make a song out of like
any genre you could cross genres you
could do whatever you wanted it was just
like this big explosion of
uh of creativity so the fact that you
could have a number one charting song
that was essentially like an irish real
yeah uh alongside like some other kind
of like crazy ass yeah you know what i
mean then you had like people that were
a little more underground like klaus
know me that's just like oh i'm doing
new wave but also opera yeah uh you know
what i mean so besides buffalo girls
right so it's not a wrap right so you
could kind of do like whatever you would
it's like there were no
restrictions as to like genre everybody
was just like mixing [ __ ] and it was
[ __ ] crazy but it was all very
personalized yes it was real
personalized yeah so it so i kind of
feel like there was a lot more
uh at least like oral
uh a-u-a-r-l not o-r-a-l uh diversity
yeah um in the sense that you had like a
lot of cross genre type of stuff getting
to the top of the charts just because it
was like super catchy or whatever right
um which
i don't know i i don't know how uh i
don't know how
still because i don't know anything
about charts nowadays or even if that's
still a thing i don't think i don't even
think it's the thing anymore no um so
does anyone care it was just well
this
that era music was our social media
yes it was it was kind of like a meme
that would go
so these songs were kind of like memes
that would go viral
they were meant to be it was one person
talking to a couple of other people it
was like reading somebody else's mail
but you could relate to it because
people are in general are the same
and they have a lot of the same things
uh okay in the example of [ __ ] come
on eileen that made the basic message is
it's
a guy
saying to some young girl
who's who might be a little too young
for him actually
saying that
the [ __ ] that our parents listen to is
long gone
this is a [ __ ] tired old town
so let me in your panties we're getting
out of here
me and you are gonna get out of here
we're gonna move the big city in london
and i'm gonna hit you know and it's
just the way the way it's written though
is had a
it was very sentimental you know one of
my favorite things about the 80s yeah
was that you could write like a really
happy
sounding catchy pop song that was about
like death and destruction and nuclear
war
yeah and everybody would be like you
know like you had like 99 red balloons
or granola yeah or songs like that which
if you just listen to it you're like
whoa it's a cool pop song
yeah it's about like uh an atomic bomb
so
it's like i just love the subversiveness
of that
um mr88 said 80s music was not so genre
decisive yeah that's a good way of
putting it yeah you could hear motley
crew and cindy lauper consecutively on
the same station and everyone would be
happy yeah pretty much now i do remember
when i was in junior high
um
there was a pretty clear divide
between people that liked
metal
uh you know motley crue that type of
stuff and people that liked new wave
duran duran psychedelic furs whatever
and uh they didn't usually hang out i
did have a friend that was a metalhead
but she used to like you know constantly
[ __ ] on me for liking new wave
and i used to constantly [ __ ] on her for
liking metal
so she used to make fun of my satin
durand rant jacket this was junior high
so i was like pretty young this was like
the 80s
and uh so there was kind of like a
divide yeah but and i wasn't really into
all the hair metal and stuff like that i
just thought that was like mainstream
and lame
um i liked more like
experimental [ __ ] or you know it's like
just like i said like [ __ ] like the
patch mode and stuff like that or like
the smiths or the cure or whatever i
like stuff like that
so
if you were into stuff like that
at least where i grew up in daytona
beach uh
you were kind of like seen as
[ __ ] yeah you know what i mean because
because all the manly people were into
motley crew because clearly that's much
more manly yeah
tina's talking about the difference
between old rap and new rap
old rap was kind of better because
it was homemade you know i mean um
yeah i like a lot of the older [ __ ] i
don't i don't really like the newer [ __ ]
as much but no
as it got as rap became a commercial
property all right and people who are
not
okay people who are not from the rap
[ __ ] community started to get in
there to [ __ ] write that music for
them
and it became a commercial property
basically you know let's be honest you
have white dudes in there writing this
[ __ ] for these black dudes it was fake
it was corporate but the old stuff like
nwa and [ __ ] um public enemy
uh you could go back to [ __ ] um even
even some of the [ __ ] that was happening
in the late 70s you know uh [ __ ] what
was the name of this looking band
oh [ __ ]
oh man i forgot the name of that dude's
name
he wouldn't fan fire freddy [ __ ] but
he said he was a dj but you can go and
and that was their music
they they wrote it
and they wrote a lot of that [ __ ] from
[ __ ] their house well yeah it was
like a grassroots kind of right that's
why it was
it was that's what made it legitimate
they were talking about people that they
knew
and things that they knew about
and um
[ __ ]
during the time that
during the time that i was listening to
skinny puppy and uh [ __ ] goth music
like
some of the goth music like like sisters
of mercy that's around the time public
enemy came out
and we were listening to that too
and we didn't really
actually ate too much between rap and
industrial to us they they sounded alike
it was just a
public enemy was kind of like the black
version of industrial
yeah it was just like a slight cultural
difference but it was like the same like
experience
anyway
and that was up in the detroit scene i
was living in detroit also around that
time and
that the detroit house scene
was kind of like where techno and and
some of the rap was coming from but it
was happening in one spot it hadn't
diverged yet
detroit was a [ __ ] good scene in the
in in the uh
late 80s early 90s interesting well if
you listen to a lot of industrial music
like from like the wax tracks area yeah
um there's a lot of like hip-hop
influence in there like there was a lot
of crossover and nobody really thought
about it because it was all like
underground yeah at that time i was
listening to skinny poppy and a friend
of mine says dude you gotta [ __ ] get
this album get this out and i'm looking
at it it's called public enemy yo bum
rush the show
and then [ __ ] i bought that out i
[ __ ] loved it it had my uzi waste a
ton in on it the [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] 98 oldsmobile
rob get up get down oozy where's the
tongue [ __ ] all this and all that
[ __ ] it fit right in with skinny puppy
and a lot of the industrial that was
happening there wasn't that big of a
difference it was just
back in those days to me it was just
black dudes doing industrial
that's that's how we looked at that yeah
like i said it was similar spirits and
it was all kind of like diy yeah you
know homemade [ __ ] sure
it had it had personality to it
and i was like okay yeah that's cool
and uh that was gangster rap
it wasn't a big difference between
industrial
it was just uh yeah you didn't really
see like in the late 80s and early 90s
you didn't really see a lot of different
i mean at least where i was and i'm sure
at least where you were uh you didn't
see a lot of differentiation
differentiation between people that were
into
uh punk or industrial or indie or
anything like that and people that were
into hip hop it was all kind of like
underground a lot if there was a lot of
crossover yeah uh between the [ __ ] we'd
go to each other's shows it wasn't
really yeah nobody really like thought
even early nwa wasn't that different
than than yeah industrialist the first
thing that i noticed that appeared that
it sounded different and i would say
kind of commercial
and
at that time i said wait a minute this
is something a little bit different so i
remembered ll cool j showed up yeah that
was very that was very commercial it was
very refined sounding and i was like
uh yeah that was kind of like that
that's not that cool the suburban yeah
right with all the rough
it's like they edges of cleaned it up
and tried to sell it to a mask yeah
that's exactly what they do i mean they
did the same thing with punk they do the
same thing with anything that's like a
big grassroots like what oh cool jake
wasn't bad it's just that that wasn't
that and then a couple years later you
had vanilla ice which didn't sound that
much different than l.l cool j yeah
and vanilla ice it was like
come on can you imagine the fight like
the audacity of
what are we doing he's [ __ ] crazy to
think about now yes that actually
happened it did happen and really it did
happen and he made a movie yeah called
cool as ice oh [ __ ] please watch it it
is so cringe actually don't watch it on
its own they they have a rifftrax
version yeah uh that's free on toby and
it's much funnier um but
even when i was watching on rifftrax i
was just kind of like oh i was like i
was like cringing with like [ __ ]
embarrassment like i was just like
everyone involved in this production i'm
just i'm feeling like
shame for them across the miles and
across the years right and it was just
oh it's terrible now some of that rap
from some of that rap
some of that rap from you know [ __ ]
nwa and public enemy some of it went
into even cooler regions there were two
bands that i'm thinking of off the top
of my head
that i really liked one of them ended up
being famous the other one was forgotten
the other one that i really ended up
liking was cypress hill i thought
[ __ ] cyprus brazil are good actually
it was [ __ ] very good it was like
chologoth rap
little goth [ __ ] gangster rap i
[ __ ] like decided for cyprusil and
another one was called new kingdom and
most people don't know what the [ __ ]
that what new kingdom is but it's out
there you can see it for free on youtube
new kingdom was southwest
desert
rap
black dudes in the desert doing mad max
[ __ ]
talking about going south to the border
talking about jimi hendrix
on a poster with a horse and a holster
you'll understand it when you hear it
imagine if
rap was southwest
yeah
it's funny because you don't really see
much of that angle no
it was at least for sure you didn't back
that artistically if you asked me
[ __ ] new kingdom was a huge success
not commercially though
commercially it didn't sell
but just go
go [ __ ] go on youtube go look for a
new kingdom the name of the album was uh
mexico or bust i think is what it was
called i think it was called mexico or
bust
badass album
badass album
yeah yeah
black dudes in the desert
black dudes
in the desert
with guns
and old cars and barely making it okay
for a while it was like a cool movie
title but now it's too long
john goris said i got called the f word
in junior high for liking talking heads
yeah so your junior high was probably
like my junior high if you were into
new wave if you were into the [ __ ] that
was on mtv yeah like
like because i was into like duran duran
modern english
psychedelic furs
talking heads i was into all that kind
of stuff uh depeche mode if you liked
that yeah then yeah you were okay
g-a-y straw dog says i remember tom
recommended new kingdom paradise don't
come cheap that's the name of the album
mexico bust is on it on that album it's
called paradise don't come cheap listen
to that album he says he still listens
to that [ __ ] today
it's got harmonica wrapped with
harmonica out in the desert
talking about jimmy hedricks
and doing
weird [ __ ] out in the desert just try to
survive mad max style
she looks great
says one of my favorite rappers is
female missy elliott yeah she's [ __ ]
great is vanilla ice a good actress do
you that says no no no
no
um
no honestly didn't he have a reality
show a few years ago i kind of feel like
i heard about this where he was like
flipping houses
am i completely crazy i don't know where
i got that information from
but um
yeah but seriously if get drunk one
night and watch don't watch cool as ice
by itself watch the rip tracks version
it's yeah
but it's a rifftrax version is a lot
better it's a lot better don't just like
watch it by itself because it is oh my
god it is
honestly i've seen a lot of christmas
[ __ ] never let that white boy rap i've
seen a lot of cringes
they also should have never let him
dress himself yeah because that [ __ ] is
out of control yeah that was out of
control he tried to apologize and go
down a different path
it was too late it was too late you
can't you can't repair yourself i mean
everybody knows who the [ __ ] you are
yeah you can't be that famous and to be
like my bad my bad i'm not vandalized
i'm this other guy i'm not really that
dorky yeah yeah
we've all seen that we see you
i'm sorry like you know what i mean i'm
[ __ ] talking heads and burning down
the house yes this is david byrne
yeah
and uh i really like it yeah uh the
dude's a genius
okay he's a genius
uh there is nothing the talking
everything the talking heads did was
gold
um artistically just road to nowhere
that's my favorite actually
those dudes could do no wrong but let me
back up a little bit david byrne that
singer is [ __ ] insufferable
he's evidently just insufferable you
can't even stand to be around that dude
in real life well something artistically
he's [ __ ] great some that people that
are like really really cool and awesome
i've heard that about lou reed also you
just can't be around
that you can't like hang out but that's
okay i don't have to hang out with them
i just have to listen their music their
music is awesome so right i don't have
to hang out with them it's cool
uh somebody talks about living color oh
yeah living color were [ __ ] great
they were good yeah i saw them on the
first lollapalooza in 1991 in atlanta
they were fantastic uh the president
that is living color was a [ __ ]
black
metal progressive band they were prague
metal they were really good
artistically good good lyrics
um and metal was not a black genre
uh but they tried to break through into
that which they kind of did um
white guys liked it black dudes didn't
like it it was it was just it was way
ahead of his time
um but they were good
although when it came to black metal or
punk type bands i'm going to have to
[ __ ] hand that [ __ ] to bad brains i
mean bad brains yeah brains was the
[ __ ] bad brains are amazing yeah
fish bone good too oh yeah i like fish
fish bone like a good party band yeah
they're like super fun they're food
super fun yeah fish bone was kind of
like a pump
punk rock
reggae band kind of
yeah it's not a good way to describe
them yeah kind of punk rock yeah reggae
they're good yeah fish ball yeah i
always had it i always had a lot but
every party you ever went to back then
you had a [ __ ] fish well i wouldn't
say they were reggae were they
they had reggae elements yeah but a lot
of things did bad yeah
[ __ ] even some goth music back in the
early 80s had some reggae bad brains bad
brains were they were [ __ ] legitimate
they had [ __ ] street cred
yeah i mean they weren't they had a lot
of albums
uh they had a [ __ ] hardcore fan base
they were recording song the singer
recorded a song from a jail cell over
the phone that's how the [ __ ]
he's singing the song because he
couldn't make it so they were singing it
singing the song through the hair just
call him he'll just think yeah yeah sing
it it'll be yeah
very good bad rings
real good
tila said i added riff tracks cool as
ice on my watch oh [ __ ]
i watched it the other because i said i
gotta see
i gotta see this so i watched it like a
few months ago and it's just like
she's got the rip track version yeah
yeah because like i said it's on to be
it's on tv free there's a lot of riff
tracks on there yeah there's a lot of
mystery sign theater episodes on there
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] is unwatchable
if it's on its own you have to watch it
with rip tracks with them even with riff
tracks like them making jokes about it
even then i was like squirming and make
your skin crawl
that's how [ __ ] uncomfortable you
will be i was just very very embarrassed
for everyone involved yeah i'm not like
that with all bad movies
you know what i mean because i in a way
like i have a lot of affection for bad
movies yeah i think that especially if
you want to make movies
i think watching bad movies is actually
more helpful and instructive than
watching good ones you should still
watch good ones
i'm not saying that but i'm just saying
that you should watch bad ones too
because
sometimes i think that teaches you more
than watching good ones because you're
like okay well i know that i don't want
to do that you know what i'm saying yeah
so
but cool as ice is its own
i can't even i can't even describe
how [ __ ]
embarrassed i was for everyone when i
was watching this movie all i could
think of when i was watching the movie
was like how
afterward
did everyone's parents like watch this
and they were like all proud of it and
[ __ ] and then like a few years later
everyone's like like
like pretending they weren't in it i was
like
i had so many questions
like
and the outfits that he wore in that
like the jacket and the [ __ ] all the
spandex yeah do you remember when that
that was a big thing like in the 90s
like all that [ __ ] glow dayglo like
spandex
yes holy [ __ ] what was that about god i
hated the 90s yeah i really hated the
90s i did and i was young then yeah like
i said i graduated from high school in
1990.
after about 1992
um
i i think i was like self-aware enough
to be like yeah i think i'm checking out
of this decade i don't like how this is
going yeah it's just i didn't
i don't know i didn't like it i didn't
like it in in retrospect um you know
there's some good stuff from then but
when i was living through it i was just
kind of like i i don't like the way
shit's going i like well entertainment
mostly i just didn't like the way it was
going i didn't like the trends in the
90s i just i hated it and now like
looking back on it
because now there's like 90s nostalgia
and i'm like now i hate it even more
i'm glad i'm glad you liked uh
i'm glad you liked uh new kingdom
i i introduced that to a couple people
they [ __ ] they still listen to it too
that's a it was a good band and i think
they only had two albums
yeah yeah tila check out new kingdom
paradise don't come cheap that's the
name of that album you'll like it it's
good
southwest rap
mad max style out in the desert with
guns and cars
and acid
and cactuses and cancers
and listening to jimi hendrix
all right when you were a kid you talked
about listening to jimi hendrix when he
was a kid yeah kevin donovan says i
think the drinks are kicking in oh yeah
of course well i mean you know this way
it is
it's friday this is this is how we do
yeah um
no i would say yeah tila says it says
that ice is a motorcycle riding bad boy
in the movie
you'll see it's terrible it's terrible
it's so bad
honestly i would rather sit through
mano's hands of fate or burdemic
shock and terror or whatever the [ __ ]
that movie is called i would rather sit
through that a hundred times than watch
cool as ice again
that's um i said it and i meant it t
that was the beginning of the end a rap
for me
that was the direction rap was going
you all have too young to remember it
you weren't there for it
that was it was awful that was the
direction rap went it went mainstream
corporate and [ __ ] cheesy as [ __ ]
and i was like no i i can't be a part of
this you know what i mean they should
they they ended up saving it later
but not for me
not for me it was too late i mean it
they saved it for younger generations
but i was like no yeah that didn't live
through that [ __ ] that we were like that
guy were like traumatized for life yeah
yeah they're like stardog78 oh thank you
for pointing this out i almost forgot
vanilla ice was in teenage mutant ninja
turtles too secret of the ooze go ninja
go ninja go yeah
here's the thing here's the thing
god damn it here's the thing no he did
flip houses okay so i didn't just make
that up oh here's that here's here's the
thing i'm not gonna [ __ ] talk [ __ ]
about vanilla ice because as a dude he
was innocent they were making him do
this
all right and they made him do this this
[ __ ] is all artificial this is all
corporate artificial [ __ ]
okay but it just in my mind it destroyed
rap uh this is a time
thank you very much for the [ __ ]
super chats that we didn't get today if
it's if you all ooh that was passing
like this
[ __ ]
if y'all want to send a super chat it's
yeti now it'd be about time we're
getting drunk
mr 88 says jen would you rather sit
through noah's shark because there
really is such a movie is there because
now i need to see that
noah's shark
oh my god i'm on that no is that a real
movie
no it better be no it's not all right
make it
dude oh my god i just
i'm writing the whole movie in my head
john's got the [ __ ] right [ __ ] video
ice was mk ultra project yeah he was
it was i think he was
that explains a lot that is quite a lot
of [ __ ] in my mind that explains a lot i
was there i was there at the right age
and [ __ ]
right the the the correct level of
development to understand what was
happening you had a bunch of corporate
[ __ ] inside the media's
white dudes
probably some jewish dudes going hey you
know this jewish project this jewish
product
this wrap product would be [ __ ] great
in the mainstream so let's kind of clean
it up and turn it into something that
white people will buy that's what they
were doing but still megan tell me
they're like edgy yeah we're gonna make
it edgy we're gonna make it black we're
going to make it black but white at the
same time because your memory kind of we
did with elvis remember what happened
with elvis yeah and then we'll sell it
to them and we'll make all kinds of
money
yeah do you remember the one scene in
coola's ice which i think was maybe the
cringiest of all and that's saying a lot
where he goes into this place it's like
a bar it's like a bar right but it's
like a yuppie bar
and everyone is like scandalized by his
very existence yeah and you know he's
there with his brand new jacket with all
the words painted on it and all their
dayglow spandex and everyone is just all
the yuppies are just kind of like oh my
god this is just
what is all this business and i'm just
like
oh my god just like even back in the 90s
this would not have happened this way
yeah which is why it was very very crazy
even at the time it was cringy
and i'm not look don't take it wrong i'm
not being i'm not being anti-white or
anti-semitic or whatever okay [ __ ]
the same thing it's just that [ __ ]
white dudes jewish dudes were the ones
that had all the [ __ ] power
in the in in the old [ __ ] music
industry they were the ones that decided
what what product we're going to be
selling they just were and they would
get uh get their hands on black product
and turn it into something that they
could sell
dj maniac he [ __ ] knows what he
talked about too
now i think he got it wrong with elvis i
don't think that's exactly what what the
deal with elvis was that was gonna
happen rock and roll was gonna happen
anyway
all right
white's people in the 50s [ __ ] love
rock and roll the young people that was
going to happen
it just it just transcended
ethnic boundaries
not rap rap was black
all right that was forced into the white
audience it just was i was there during
the time
now they liked it but that took effort
i don't think rock did
rock just it just gravitated towards
that
because there wasn't a big difference
between rock and blues and a bunch of
other stuff there wasn't it wasn't a
quantum leap
rap was a quantum leap remember yeah how
different it sounded yeah it was a
quantum leap and it had to have some
kind of backing for it to go mainstream
well somebody pointed out earlier that
it's like um
yeah midwest outlaw 420 says vanilla ice
was the gateway to rap for white folk
before eminem yeah yeah so it's i mean
it's sad that that needed to be there
but
it that was kind of why and you had and
then you had kind of like nice sounding
i don't even want to call it hip-hop but
you had kind of like
uh
[ __ ] will smith we also had trip hop
too remember
what was it what was the name of those
dudes
oh [ __ ]
it was like hip hop but it was
psychedelic sounding
oh [ __ ] i'm trying to remember
oh man it was two guys
do you remember those two guys that
amazing video two guys it was that had
everybody young they had a music video
and they're sitting on a damn
por they're sitting on a porch outside
of [ __ ] like a brownstone kind of a
part of the porch oh there was that a
video what was that [ __ ] name of that
band
it's not ringing a bell at the moment oh
man like i said a lot of the 90s they're
really good kind of like man [ __ ] this
yeah
they were really good i want to say bill
bib devoe wasn't them it was uh
number one in the charts yeah no
and um i don't know i was listening to
those guys oh man that sounds [ __ ]
great but that never went anywhere that
never would you it was something that
was pushed
before that time
rap was really just public enemy and nwa
that's that's what that it was gangster
rap well they had to make it like less
dangerous they had to make it less
dangerous they had to widen it yeah and
therefore like more palatable to brian
which is ridiculous because you had
[ __ ] skinny puppy was hard as [ __ ]
that was kind of like
the white version of [ __ ] publicly
like a lot of people kind of like
midwestern like suburban white people
weren't listening to that kind of stuff
that was a little like off their radar
industrial white industrial went
mainstream basically with nine inch
nails that's when it went mainstream
[ __ ] trip
big time which he just kind of turned it
more towards rock which you could sell
it that way
i didn't really like it that much i was
like that's kind of watered down
sounding it was kind of like well the
thing about it like it's weird because i
mean we i mean some of you guys might
remember too because like we were there
when this happened
um when the first nine inch nails album
came out pretty hate machine
um
i had it like someone uh pirated it for
me because it was the early 90s it was
1990 or 1991 and i was broke as [ __ ]
i think it was 1990.
and so someone fired it for me and i
actually quite liked it um but it wasn't
like a real it wasn't a huge thing and
then i remember i went to see i went to
st petersburg
and i saw peter murphy
in 1990 when uh deep had just come out
yeah and that was kind of like his
biggest album at the time
so i went to uh the mahaffey theater in
st petersburg and i saw peter murphy
nine inch nails opened
for him
and pretty hate machine had just come
out i had it because i had a friend that
had it and he copied it for me because
like i said i was too broke to buy it
and
they played
and the whole theater just sat there and
looked at them nobody like knew who they
were at this point um you know the album
hadn't really like proliferated to any
great degree
so it's just funny like i knew who they
were because i'd heard the out the
pirated album and i was just kind of
like oh okay cool i was in the front row
and uh but everyone was just kind of
like oh okay
where's peter murphy
you know what i mean so it's like really
really funny to me that like nine inch
nails got like so [ __ ] huge later
because i saw them when like everyone
was just kind of like okay can you like
hurry up so peter murphy can come on now
yeah that was like 1990. they're in
there trying to give me uh ask me is it
diosol or whatever they come up with
different no it's not them it was two
dudes oh yeah i remember them it was two
young guys
it was a very positive sounding kind of
rap
um but it was also kind of ambient
from what i remember of
man i'm trying to remember the name of
those dudes
judd mouse says maybe diggable planets i
remember them too
milly eventually no it wasn't
really vanilla oh that whole scandal
about yeah that [ __ ] came out
to the damn [ __ ] record
girl you know it's true yeah girl you
know
it's true
yeah
i'll tell you what though this those
songs are great some of y'all might know
what i'm talking about yeah the
millionaire
those millions
yeah yeah
okay if y'all know what we're talking
about they had bag called millie vanilla
it was these
two good looking black dudes they were
in shorts weren't they
weren't they in shorts
everybody had [ __ ] little day glow
spandex shorts and white yeah the [ __ ]
was that about stupid little [ __ ]
hats and [ __ ] you had like okay so you
had like white spandex shorts and then
you had like kind of a kind of a
form-fitting shirt and then like a
blazer yeah what the [ __ ] was that about
yeah but they were good-looking dudes
and they were [ __ ] they were
good-looking dudes they would be doing
synchronized dancing and they had a
[ __ ] good songs like girl you know
it's true i don't remember all the
[ __ ] lyrics i don't either i remember
the songs being very catchy and and very
good quality music
but you know it was all too good to be
true those [ __ ] were [ __ ] models
they were just lipsticking to
to to music written and sung by some fat
dudes it was actually some fat dudes
well yeah well because they were kind of
like well this is awesome braids long
braids but the
but the producers were probably like
well no one wants to see y'all's fat
asses parading around on it too pretty
[ __ ] so let's get some like hot
dudes yeah up there at which point the
fat guys were kind of like yeah but yeah
put them up there that's our song though
yeah you know i don't know that's how
fake it was back in the 90s
and then like i said they got caught
because it was i don't remember was
skipping was it the mtv it was some live
show
and this is how [ __ ] lo-fi the [ __ ]
was they didn't have like digital [ __ ]
they were playing like a wreck
like behind the [ __ ] stage
and the record started to skip yeah
and they have they were trying to like
play it off oh my god so funny i still
remember when that happened midwest
outlaw 420 says you all talked about
nine inch nails but what about throbbing
gristle i'm actually i i actually really
liked robin gristle taylor goes oh my
god i just watched a bit of the video
milly vanilli's truly 80s it wasn't 80s
it was 90s that was well yeah it was no
well wait i think that was late 80s or
early 90s no 1989 i thought it was 89.
no i think it was
92 right 91.92 now i can't remember it's
all blurring together very ladies are
either not yeah but no they were [ __ ]
blame it on the rain that was the other
one blame it on the rain it's falling
and that's the only part of the song
that i remember seriously
for the time the music was great for pop
music that was you know i mean that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] selling like hot cakes
and the way the dudes looked they were
the right look for the right time
they were the second has some black
dudes they look like twins
with [ __ ] long braids and [ __ ] i
remember the black clothing and the
[ __ ] hats and i thought they were
wearing shorts and [ __ ]
the girls [ __ ] loved them
my [ __ ] ex-girlfriend marilyn she
[ __ ] loved her that girl from [ __ ]
24
maryland ricegum she loved millie
vanilli oh it's all coming [ __ ] love
she's famous that's right she would have
[ __ ] just thrown giving out the ass
like [ __ ]
sideways for that i was too cold to like
milk she's [ __ ] love millie vanilli i
didn't know and [ __ ] it
turned out they were fake yeah so now
they were fake it was actually some fat
dudes [ __ ] singing that music
which had they just had the fat dudes up
there singing it would have worked out
[ __ ] better i think yeah why didn't
they just do that it's like uh it was a
it was a it was a commercial product
well yeah
exactly nobody wants to see fat people
sing even though that's actually their
song right and they actually sang it
that was the problem the problem was is
that you know you had a
a
a very
narrow bandwidth from the medium from
the media
you only had a few a few channels on
on [ __ ] cable television and the
competition was tough
so everyone had to
be a perfect product or at least that's
what the corporations thought
i never thought that but the people that
controlled those television channels
thought that
which is dumb because if they'd have
just like opened it up and let the [ __ ]
fly
like nowadays it's like you could be
ugly and be fat it doesn't matter
like are you [ __ ] talented can you
sing can you like do some [ __ ] are you
interesting okay i'll watch it well when
you went back to the early 80s with the
british new wave and just the new wave
music that came a lot of the really cool
[ __ ] was done by ugly people sure just
that you didn't know it because it was
just on the radio look at shane [ __ ]
mcgowan from the pogues for christ's
sake oh yeah that dude looks like a
[ __ ] truck backed up into his face he
was like a drunk he had like his teeth
were all falling out and he's just well
he was constantly drawn
and then they had that little but they
were a great [ __ ] hey that little fat
mexican girl [ __ ] singing that song
back in the 80s it was [ __ ] badass
romeo boyd that's what somebody was
talking about yeah what was the name of
that song never say never yeah never say
never yeah right tila go look and never
say never
what's it romeo romeo yeah romeo void
never say never it's a grey song
and it's got this little [ __ ]
4 foot 11 250 pound
little fat mexican girl
singing that song
and it sounds great it sounds great and
that [ __ ] that song's
[ __ ] sold anyway it didn't matter
play it now yeah it didn't matter that
she's a little fat girl that actually
kind of added to it never say never
[ __ ] yeah it just it didn't matter
it's only the corporate suits thought
that it mattered i think
yeah and i mean like i said i'm not i
don't think it's entirely dumb that they
thought that because yeah
um being like hot and perfect and stuff
like that that does it it helps i'm not
saying
um
but
i don't think they should have gone so
far as to like [ __ ] fake it no yeah
don't fake it if you got a good song
don't fake it let let the [ __ ] just let
the yeah just let the fat out the fact
that people hit it i mean sell it like
that yeah you know what i mean just let
them be them you gotta you have to
modify your sales pitch sure
to fit that product yeah that's how i
would would have done it i mean that
just seems really dumb we're just gonna
get like these other people that can't
sing right um to impersonate these other
people for these people that we think
are not uh worthy to be on camera that's
kind of [ __ ] up that's kind of [ __ ]
up
honestly a lot of people [ __ ] about
nowadays but i would rather see the
actual people
that were actually singing i don't care
what they look like
um if you got a good voice and you got a
thing going on
whatever it is and you're working it
then
it's fine you don't have to look like a
model no one cares about that
yeah just you know just give me some
good entertainment you don't have to
look a particular way
but uh yeah new kids on the block
somebody brought up it's been a long
time yeah i remember that um somebody
said to let's see uh rodney marsh says
i'm not entirely sure what this question
means
were people tight with the electricity
and gas in the 80s or is it just my dad
what are you talking about like tight as
in stingy with a stingy with electricity
what country are you in
[Laughter]
in the 80s i don't really remember that
i was a kid in the 80s too i was born i
was born in 1972. you were born in 1869.
we didn't really have gas where i was i
didn't yeah we didn't either i had
electricity i didn't have gas everything
was electric um
it was just kind of like but i don't
know
i did know some people that were weird
about
electricity like turn the lights off or
i had an uncle
this is [ __ ] up i had an uncle i'm not
saying what his name is
but um
he
would make you like if you just peed you
couldn't you weren't allowed to flush
yeah because it was like wasting water
so i hated staying over at their house
because i was just kind of like oh my
god that's so gross but
but i didn't and also this was the same
dude that would like drive several
several miles to like save like 10 cents
on a product at a different version
graham says that
me and graham came up together new kids
on the block once sang at a bowling
alley tom played video games and trent
true how did you know about that did
they really yeah probably true
did you like not notice probably the
bowling alley uh out in front of [ __ ]
trenton hi were you there at the same
time no not saying hi
and then um so here's probably what he's
talking about
uh tila says that [ __ ]
tita said something about no no that was
mr 88 she goes what about sid vicious
he's one of the most famous punk rockers
ever and his role in the sex pistols was
completely fake and image driven uh
there's some no actually not well not a
hundred percent he couldn't play all
that well he couldn't play that well he
isn't on the record
if you go on
youtube and go watch there's a there's a
good
sex pistols live show
um on youtube
and it's not
it's in the united states i don't think
it's texas though
he is playing it's a great show
he could play
but not at the time of of the recording
of the album he learned to play a bit
after like he played a bit on it and
they were like yeah no right so they
like wiped them off
the bass lines on never mind the
bullocks are very simple
you could teach me those bass lines and
i could do them
well i i learned to play those when i
was a teenager so they're not super hard
right he could play
a little bit
he could put on a show that's what he
was up there to do he was up there to
put on a show
and if you see him live
um
on youtube on that show he puts on a
good show
he's good you can hear him play he's not
a great musician obviously but he was
just there he was interested in enter he
was an entertainer
he was there to do crazy [ __ ] yeah
and another thing that's kind of
not accurate
john lydon also known as johnny rotten
he will go on about how much
america hated them when they would throw
things at them and it's [ __ ]
i mean it's probably dependent on where
it was it's obvious that when you look
at that show it's obvious that the
people that have paid money to see them
know who they are
they know what punk rock culture is yeah
they're throwing things but they're not
throwing anything that'll hurt you it's
not like they're throwing
cans of camel soup they're throwing
pieces of paper and girls are throwing
their phone numbers
at john well i kind of feel like there
was a culture of punks being like
throwing their like spitting on people
that was kind of like
they are spitting on each other
but look at the video
it's cute girls
up front
flirting with the band they're spitting
on each other
they'd be swapping spit anyway anyway
they're trying to [ __ ]
these people would be [ __ ] each other
and normals
it's they're they are having fun
uh
it is taking place in the punk rock
spirit of things
but they're making a big deal out of
this
but they're definitely enjoying the band
they're um
they know the songs you can hear them
singing
uh
no one is trying to really uh undermine
or stop the band from playing
so i'm watching it and going no these
are fans
watching this
they're just doing it in the punk rock
way
be a judge for yourself it's right there
on youtube you'll see
well yeah and well like i said a lot of
it is part of the myth making it's myth
making sure all this stuff about all
they're trying to try well one of the
things about punk was that they were
trying to be very contrary yeah so it's
like they didn't want to be acceptable
they didn't want to be i mean they
wanted to like offend people so that was
kind of like their whole thing yeah if
they just went somewhere and everybody
loved them and kissed their asses
then
that wouldn't really be what they were
about you know well
from what i saw in that show the people
that were the people that were in the
audience paid to see him knew who they
were
i would think you're not going to get i
kind of feel like you'd have to be a
really hardcore troll to pay to go see a
band that you hated right just so you
could heckle them right that seems a
little
that's not what yeah extreme what i saw
was i saw fans
okay i mean there's a lot of musicians
and people and [ __ ] like that that i
hate but i would never dream of paying
money to go see them just so i could
yell at them it was a show that had i
been there i would have enjoyed it and i
would have considered everybody else as
having enjoyed the punk rock band
and uh yeah we're enjoying the punk rock
[Laughter]
and um we're enjoying the podcast sid
put on a great show and he did play and
uh
people enjoyed him and he was acting
[ __ ] a fool and that was his job
uh so i would have i would have been
satisfied
yeah i kind of feel like he had a little
bit maybe this is extreme but he does he
did have a little bit of the court
jester kind of yeah thing to it where
he's just like everybody's gonna show up
and see what crazy [ __ ] right was he
gonna break a bottle and like scratch
himself like iggy pop used to do yeah
like and scratch [ __ ] into his chest and
why not they got a full show on youtube
go ahead and be a judge for yourself
to me i've seen a lot of shows like that
and that's fans
yeah
in boston that's the way it was we
received [ __ ] sheer terror or
something like that or the other punk
rock bands are like that so no that was
fans and they they had a good show and
everybody liked them and
and they all put on a good show all this
stuff about you know i mean oh well they
wanted to kill us in texas i know
they're throwing things that's john
lyden
myth making you know no they had fans
that might have been somewhere other
than at their shows
but yeah not the shows at the shows
those people paid to see you they knew
exactly who they were
you would think
yeah they knew the lyrics i could hear
them singing yeah unless they just
turned up and played and nobody knew
what they were i could hear this i could
hear the audience [ __ ] singing the
lyrics and so no they knew who they were
john gorra says people loved janice
joplin and she was pretty homely yeah
janice joplin was is [ __ ] amazing i
love you there's some you know what
though let's be honest joplin was there
was something kind of sexy about her
yeah that's what i'm saying
you don't have to be like look like a
model to be sexy it's two different
things she was kind of like this dirty
hippie kind of chick that you might want
to [ __ ] yeah that's that's what she was
that's what i mean she had a she had
like a real kind of like vibe about her
yeah that was kind of like and she was
like [ __ ] amazing like my
understanding she was bisexual she you
weren't safe around her if you were a
pretty girl either evidently she was
that's that's what i had heard all right
yeah she liked girls
but she like guys too but even and she
like girls that's cool
yeah i like i like janice joplin yeah
it's funny i was just thinking of that
uh leonard cohen song yeah chelsea hotel
number two yeah which is actually it's
about her although it doesn't it doesn't
bring her up by name but it is actually
about her yeah and um
he says in that song
that one of the things she said to him
was uh i think the lyric is we are ugly
but we have the music yeah yeah because
yeah i mean letter cohen i mean letter
cohen i think is rather handsome but i
guess he was kind of like a
little bit of a
kind of thing too because he wasn't like
classically good looking so there was
that whole thing where
we're not good looking but
we're good musicians so there's that
um let me see jesse
john smith says yep nowadays johnny
rotten's a property developer and
married to a german media heiress yeah
taylor says new kids on the block is
touring this summer laura's saying that
iron maiden early days
iron maiden in the early days was like
punk it was better yeah the uh
paul diana
paul giano uh iron maiden for the first
two albums
that's actually my favorite iron maiden
i liked bruce dickinson
uh you know the peace of mind album
power slave [ __ ] number of the beasts
they were good too
but they were just something about paul
giano it was it was like you said a
little bit more punk rock it was a
little more street
it had a kind of a hot
searing kind of sound to it
the iron maiden and [ __ ] killers
album i think were like
on a spontaneous level were better
albums
technically they weren't but [ __ ]
emotionally they were the better albums
midwest outlaw 420 says would still bang
janice joplin lol yeah i probably would
too uh not gonna lie
john gore said gigi allen would spray
diarrhea at his fans yes he did uh so
you know i was friends with one of gg
allen's friends
and i'm not into the poop yeah
you know what i mean yeah his name was
tyrone it was [ __ ] the only white
dude i ever known in tyrone but his name
was ty
he was friends with the dead boys too
he's from boston and uh i love the dead
boys yeah he was friends with the devil
i think he was in the dead boys for a
little while
uh but i never quite sorted that out he
was in some other bands um met him at
the rathskeller that's gone now that was
in boston the puck rock bar sex pistols
played there actually
but uh
he said gg was
good before he got famous but when he
was trying
and then he got famous for being an ass
and he would focus just on that he would
[ __ ] up his own shows so he didn't have
to perform and was going to jail he you
just try to make a name for himself by
going out going to jail
and that saved him the [ __ ] trouble
of having to perform
and uh ty was kind of mad at gigi and
then gigi got killed in jail
for that stupid [ __ ] see that's what i
kind of feel like because there's a lot
of that [ __ ] going around too now that
everybody's like you know trying to make
money like online and whatnot and so
everybody's kind of like well i'm just
going to do like really dumb [ __ ] right
like to make money
which
it might work
but not for long
yeah i kind of feel like that's going to
be like old hat like a few weeks from
now when everybody moves on to something
else so it's just kind of like i don't
know i don't know how sustainable that
model is and i'm just like not really i
wouldn't have any fun doing that anyway
i don't enjoy being gross i don't enjoy
being an [ __ ]
i don't
ty said that gigi got lazy
that he could make a name for himself
just by getting in trouble
i mean i could okay so i could see how
that thought process would come about
it's like look i do all this work like
you know i write songs i perform i do
this and that but it's like all anybody
cares about is like me pooping and like
throwing it on them and everybody thinks
that's awesome and i get all the press
for that so why don't i just do that do
that right um instead of like working
and doing this other [ __ ] i get it i do
yeah but
like i said i i i just feel like that's
not really sustainable and you're just
really like kind of digging yourself
into a pit that you're never gonna be
able to get out of it was another time
sure the time before social media
so you had to compete to be mentioned on
television for just a few seconds to get
fame yeah and
that was better than doing whole shows
but now that you have
youtube it's a totally different game
you couldn't do that now
you have to
produce product
um yeah you have to make your own fans
there is no mainstream to be mentioned
in anymore so yeah you know and the
thing about it is that and we've talked
about this before because it's like yes
there is kind of a thing about
oh my god this person did this like
stupid or crazy thing on tiktok and they
got like four bajillion views and they
made all this money out of it but it's
like i don't know to me it just seems
like i don't know it's it almost seems
like cheating or it seems like kind of
cheap and it's not sustainable he knows
gigi allen and most people know gigi
allen because he was mentioned on
geraldo
okay yeah he's like look at this like
extreme ass [ __ ] you've got raw
throwing poop on people you got geraldo
dictating who's famous right okay that
would never happen today no
no one cares about her no number one
is he still alive even he's around he's
on fox news oh
so he might as well be dead
[Laughter]
he's a democrat
next to mention media says just watched
a couple of scenes from cold as ice on
youtube after you talked about it
earlier yeah i'm gonna need a lot more
weed to get through that yeah do you see
what i'm saying cold is okay look it is
so it is the cringiest movie i've ever
watched they're not saying something me
and jenny watched cold as ice laying up
on our bed
on riptrax drunk enrichment we watched
the rooftops yeah we're drinking tequila
and [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] i got the
damn starry [ __ ]
the galaxy
yeah we have the galaxy light thing yeah
it looks like a nightclub in there it's
nice and i'm going that that's what you
have you watch those old movies under
the influence of [ __ ] pretty lights
in your room and [ __ ] alcohol going
what the [ __ ] and you don't want to
watch any of that anything like that
alone you'd probably get dead depressed
yeah i probably won't yeah i mean
honestly okay so i'm gonna say like like
i said i i'm a fan of bad movies
um and i like i love rifftrax i love
mystery science theater but there's a
particular kind of bad movie of which
cool is ice is one
that just makes me kind of sad
that movie made me kind of sad like some
bad movies are just so unapologetically
terrible that i'm just kind of like all
right i'm just having fun with this
that movie
i couldn't really have fun with it
because i kept
my brain kept going to like oh my god
everybody in this must be so embarrassed
now and like their parents must be so
embarrassed and it's like they're your
parents oh my god yeah and it's just
kind of like so i was just i just had
these [ __ ] like
i had shame for the people in the movie
and so i couldn't like relax and like
laugh at it because
i just felt so bad okay look i gotta you
know what i mean i just felt so bad for
the people in the movies i was just like
oh my god i'm just saying
and she's obsessed with staying in the
set them free [ __ ] song okay
set them free set them free free free
set them free if you love someone
if you love somebody yeah look
sting was the [ __ ] okay and
motherfucker's a damn musical
genius all right but he is insufferable
that is an insufferable [ __ ] prayer
well again okay that's a [ __ ]
wants to sit in a loaded position like
that and talk about spirituality of [ __ ]
not only your wife but your daughter
that's what you're talking about right
there that [ __ ] would be totally
willing [ __ ] trying to [ __ ]
your wife and your daughter behind some
magical mystical [ __ ] okay he's a
[ __ ] trick [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] all
[ __ ] he's a punk and he's a [ __ ] all
[ __ ] wrapped up [ __ ] that [ __ ] he's
gonna [ __ ] your daughter for like five
hours yeah yeah in a tantric position
he's not gonna load his position like
that he's not even gonna move it's just
his lingam the [ __ ] like just lick him
he's gonna do some indian [ __ ]
he's just gonna will it to like come up
in there like that you know that's
that's that's what he's gonna do and
she's gonna like go to the other
dimension and it's gonna be like yeah
another dimension and then they're gonna
be all [ __ ]
mystical mystical [ __ ] sexuality
that [ __ ] is insufferable don't
let that [ __ ] around anybody you
know but his music's awesome though yeah
yeah he's good he's good um
actually uh when he went when he went
solo that was actually a pretty good
album
uh t if you like that you want to go
back to the police
that's where he was really good
synchronicity was the greatest album
that i bought with my own money yeah
like i was 11 when again yeah
i had albums before that but other
people had bought them for me because
that was the machine album the ghost in
the machine album was good i loved it
what was that santa gotta what was it uh
zenyatta zenyatta
something
he was british okay and he kind of came
from a punk rock
background and punk rockers in england
didn't listen to what was in the damn
jukebox because they couldn't stand
[ __ ] prog rock they're not gonna be
listening to allen
allen parsons project and [ __ ] pink
floyd they didn't listen to they
listened to reggae
so they put a lot of reggae in their
music because that's what punk rocker is
listening to
um even though he was kind of like
the police was [ __ ] prague rock
for punk rock that'd be kind of a way to
to describe it although i think they
were very reggae influenced yeah
their version of progressivism was to
put [ __ ] reggae in it it was
very reggae very [ __ ]
rock
it was very edgy to mix your [ __ ] with
reggae back in the old days because that
was
black music and if you like that [ __ ]
you got to see you got to see that
[ __ ] movie that he was in about when
he plays that [ __ ] demon
brave cena tree called brimstone and
treacle
sting was actually honestly
i actually liked a lot of the movies
that he was in i wouldn't be [ __ ]
with him and calling him all kinds of
[ __ ] and [ __ ] if he wasn't
respectable
it's because he's respectable i mean i
know he was in doing and everybody knows
about him with the panties and
everything right but he was in like
other movies he was in brimston and
trevor he was [ __ ] great in that yeah
i honestly yeah maybe this is a guilty
pleasure i'm not sure
loved him as victor frankenstein in the
bride yeah yeah he was good in them i'm
kind of into that maybe i haven't seen
it a long time but i started a bunch of
times back on cable and i'm just like i
was a kid i kind of love that movie with
jennifer beale i was a kid
watching
sting do his thing [ __ ] was hot
[ __ ] was hot
okay he was women were just they just
my little [ __ ] 12 year old ass just
couldn't i was just like god damn i wish
i could do with that you can't compete
couldn't compete
he's a handsome guy very talented
uh very up in his own booty okay he's
like okay
his music's good i don't gotta listen to
him talk
you know what i mean and honestly that's
kind of how i feel about a lot of
because a lot of musicians that i liked
a lot of them but some of the musicians
that i like that have gone maybe off the
deep end sometimes and in their weird
views and stuff but i'm just kind of
like you know what i don't have to
listen to you talk just don't talk
just let me listen to your music and
shut up yeah so i will give him then i
will be happy i will give him this he's
not as bad as bono
that's true bonner was [ __ ] worse
hardly anybody's bad as bono and i mean
bono has a gigantic ego yeah
and i like bono i like his [ __ ] the
early youtube albums [ __ ] war and boy
those two albums were [ __ ] i liked
you two up until the joshua tree joshua
tree was a great album
i was kind of like actually
actually uh [ __ ]
baby was good i liked don't touch it i
didn't like i liked it i didn't love it
i liked it i didn't love it it was more
modern it was not like the other albums
but it was good too it was good october
baby was good
uh but you know what what ruined [ __ ]
u2 was bono
couldn't keep his [ __ ] mouth shut
if i didn't know who bono was i'd have
continued maybe [ __ ] listening to
youtube movie but youtube music but he's
just talking too much let me make
another album another one
i'm gonna make her album not make her
drink thank you yeah go in the other
room and make me an album and then play
it for me we'll see if it's good
but yeah i mean honestly i don't know
cause man
i don't know you guys know as much as i
like love the smiths back in the old
days and then like lately morrissey has
really again kind of gone off the deep
end and it makes me kind of sad and
honestly it pisses me off because now i
love morrissey's solo stuff but now i
can't listen to it without thinking
about what a [ __ ] chode he's become
uh so it really kind of like taints
everything i can still listen to the
smiths without too much trouble but a
lot of his solo stuff i just can't
listen to it anymore without thinking
goddammit what the [ __ ] happened to you
man but the thing uh you know that
that's the thing i kind of feel like i
don't know i don't want to be one it's
still a person it's like they have
opinions uh they have every right to
spout them just like everyone else does
just because they're famous but
sometimes if i like their music i just
kind of wish they would like shut up and
like not talk
and just
and just do their music and be happy
with that
tila says what's the best bad movie ever
hmm
now are we talking about like bad movie
as in like really bad movie or bad movie
as in
like deliberately bad movie i don't know
because i kind of feel like maybe me and
tom will probably say the last pastor
because i mean that was certainly the
most enjoyable bad movie that i've seen
lately
um but they knew it was a bad movie
there's two tiers of bad movies you have
a bad movie where
the movie makers were intending to make
a good movie but something went terribly
terribly awry
and then you have
the kind of thing where people were
intending to make a bad movie like a
like on purpose and those don't usually
turn out all that well
unless you really know what you're doing
it's an art form
and like i said that's why we like
velocipastor so much because that's a
bad movie and they knew they were making
a bad movie but they didn't [ __ ] it up
it's not too self-aware
to be
like it's still like um earnest enough
that it's still like entertaining
but still self-aware enough that you can
still you know what i mean so they like
they knew what they're doing it's a hard
balance destroyer so t goes back and
starts looking at all the police stuff
look at it [ __ ] don't say don't stand
so close to me i love that song actually
synchronicity too yeah say
that whole album synchronicity is
[ __ ] good [ __ ] miscredenkos on it
or is this all all kinds of good i still
love that
i still love that the police didn't have
any bad albums i don't think they did
zenyatta mandato was in the name of that
fight i knew i would remember
they didn't have any bad albums ghost in
the machine another good one it was real
that was also very good yeah
um
i mean he was a cutie yeah that well
they all kind of were it was just a it
was a trio it was three dudes they were
looking good
sting was kind of like the front man uh
he had a look about himself a [ __ ]
great sound his voice is good they were
all very talented eddie eddie summers
what was the other guy's name uh
stuart couple stuart copeland that's
right stewart copeland has actually done
a lot of film scores if you look into
his [ __ ] like a [ __ ] ton of yeah of
course you're not talking about
lightweights these these are legendary
dudes you know what i mean uh so
they were just some of the best that
britain had to offer that time and i
would call them they were part of the
british new wave
uh very good real good real good
holy [ __ ] what pokey
did you hear that yeah
walking on the moon that's walking on
the moon yeah that's a great song yeah
brought that up yeah
walking on the moon
i hope my leg don't break
yeah all that [ __ ]
um i love that yeah i love the police
honestly another good one um
t was uh from that same era
it was duran duran
duran drammer really good
they didn't have any bad albums
they're like oh they're on these in the
80s right in the 80s
big thing wasn't that good that was
their first album that was kind of big
thing was the last one of theirs that i
bought yeah that i liked a couple songs
on it but after that i felt like well
i'm not gonna buy any other [ __ ] anymore
right but then another album came out
after that that had uh that was better
remember that it had well they did the
wedding album that i think was all
covers yeah which was
odd what was the aqua green button that
came out a big thing though it it has
all kinds of hits on it [ __ ] man
[Music]
i can't remember the like the album that
had come on done on it was good too
because i love that song but honestly
when you talk about duran duran i'm
mostly into like their 80s [ __ ] and i
like yeah i like them and i like arcadia
too they only did one album yeah arcadia
was like so red the rose yeah arcadia
that was like prog rock it was that came
out in 85. it was a duran ram project
album it had half a drandran on it yeah
three of them were on it had the uh
[ __ ] but then it had like the dude it
had what's this what's his ass from uh
that program from emerson lake and
palmer
was there a summer station are you going
to tell me no no like power station was
uh john john and andy taylor and with
robert robert palmer no i'm talking
about uh arcadia so read the rose had
keith emerson i think it was keith
emerson yeah uh played with them they
had david bowie on there they had grace
jones on there
um but it was very proud rocky but i was
into it i liked it go on there and go
look at arcadia re-election day it's a
video
it's just called election election day
it's not called re-election day no it's
election election day okay because he's
saying re-election day i know but the
song is called election day trust me
it's called election day you'll [ __ ]
like it honestly all the songs on there
are good i liked uh missing is probably
my favorite but uh lady ice is good yeah
and on that album
yeah
yeah on that album was uh the girl from
[ __ ] um
vamp
yeah i just said gracious grace jones
grace jones is on that album yeah she's
singing she's on el diablo yeah el
diablo also yeah
that's a great that i love that album i
still have like a bunch of songs from it
in my on my phone
uh john goris points out duran duran had
a really scary music video to nightboat
very oh my god i love it's a good song
yeah i love nightbot that was from their
first album from 1981 yeah uh probably
one of my favorite honestly i like every
song on that album but yeah yeah that
that uh video was like super creepy yeah
i honestly like all of the uh videos
from that yeah so they did planet earth
they did careless memory or careless
memories um
i think they did one more video after
you see tila likes [ __ ] uh save a
prayer and [ __ ] uh rio and all that
oh my god
you'll you'll like i mean rio is a great
[ __ ] you'll like arcadia go look at
[ __ ] election day
you'll like that and and [ __ ] and el
diablo
that whole don't did they i don't think
they did a video for ldl no because i
don't think that was a single no i was
trying to think like election day was a
single yeah goodbye is forever yeah that
was the same goal
did they do another single from that i
don't know
[ __ ] i can't remember see there was a
there was a year there where where
where duran dram broke up into two bands
yeah 85. there's 85. and it broke up
into
[ __ ] arcadia which is power stage
which was simon nick and roger right and
and others arcadia
arcadia sounded more like duran duran
powers but a prague rocky direction
right and darker though almost dark wave
and then power station had robert palmer
singing on it it was more like
copper
gong yeah bank of gold which is a mark
bowling t-rex yeah real good single you
know
yeah bang it gone getting on yeah yeah
they uh that was john and andy who were
the more rocker guys and then they had
robert palmer he's watching arcadia now
re-election election day yeah it's good
there's two different election days
there's a long version of it where it's
like [ __ ] really long the video
and then there's kind of like a
theatrical lease really the single
version is single versus a lot shorter
they cut a lot out of it yeah and the
single version is what you which
basically what you got on the right on
the record
no the the longer version is on the
record is it the singer yeah because i
had the did i have it okay i had it too
the single version is the one that was
in the video okay on the album you got
the longer version
which has the extras with grace jones
and stuff in it okay because then okay
then there's a third version there's
like an extended version
where there's that was the remix that
was the remix that was the b side okay
of the single because i had that as well
yeah so that was like the dance remix
yeah whatever
yeah they did that a lot back then
because like i said back in the 80s
i was a big like duran duran collector
uh so whenever they would put a single
out
uh they used to do these things called
12-inch singles
because some of you guys are old enough
to probably remember which was like a
record size but it only had one song and
it was like usually a long dance remix
on one side and then on the other side
they usually had like a a different mix
like usually a dub version with no
lyrics and then they would have like
another song so i had like a bunch of
arcadia ones i had a bunch of duran
duran ones like i had union of the snake
which had like this super long like
[ __ ] 10 minute version of union of
the snake on it like a dance remix and
then on the b side it had like a weird
dub version and then it had like um i
think secret october which is actually
one of my favorite duran duran songs
still to this day it was just a b-side
it was just a throw away that's such a
great song around that period um
with arcadia and duran duran the main
the main thrust of the idea was
was was glamour
glamour and kind of like a [ __ ]
kind of like a dirty glamour because
when you listen to what they're talking
about they're talking about hookers
and blow
and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
college students who turn tricks it's
sucking oh that a lot of that [ __ ] is
what they're talking about in those
songs you have to [ __ ] understand you
have to pay attention to the lyrics
those were bad boys they were they
didn't they kind of had a glamorous
image
but when you when you
pay attention what they're talking about
it's very decadent
decadent [ __ ] but i think
that's kind of weird that's what made
him cool yeah that was like but they're
part of their appeal yes they were very
much like some out of james bond
um you had to think too that
you
somebody like duran duran you have to
think that it's like it was it would
have been like really hard to do what
they did in the 80s because
usually there was a clear distinction
between
people that were into like new wave or
punk rock that were kind of like more
they liked like
they didn't like all the glamour [ __ ]
because that was like mainstream 80s
[ __ ]
so duran duran who were kind of
mainstream
and all their videos were like super
glamorous and like we were going to
these like fabulous locations like
montserrat and stuff and we're like
filming these fantastic videos that look
like an indiana jones movie
um
but they still somehow like we're all on
a yacht
yeah drinking margaritas or whatever and
it's like somehow
they were still cool though yeah which
like i said normally like punk rockers
like people that were into like post
punk or whatever would hate that right
because it was but
but they were still good yeah the back
story to all that is dudes from duran
duran suzies and the sex pistols and
billy idol and all the people from the
british new wave
kind of came from the same background
they were came out of the same group of
clubs yeah they were ghetto all right uh
yeah i mean duran duran came from they
were from birmingham yeah uh and they
hung out at steve strange steve strange
from visage yeah uh and he had a bunch
of clubs so they hung out there
yeah i met i met his mom actually yeah
but in wales
but um because my
ex-mother-in-law was friends with steve
strange's mom which is bizarre it's
random but it's true yeah um but yeah so
they kind of came up from they were all
like our school kids
um and they were all very working class
and it was just kind of like a whole
scene they hung out at the same clubs
and there was kind of a whole thing
where the punk rockers were kind of like
we you know we're just like poor kids
poor kids were pinning our clothes
together but they were like well no
we're they're aspirational right so
they're like we want to look fabulous we
want to look like fantastic which like i
said you can see like how that happened
a little bit so they were more like got
into like the new romantic thing which
also spawned like you know again visage
with spandau ballet uh bands like that
so they're like we just want to like
fake it till we make it yeah which they
did directly
they did these are poor guys you know
they they had the proper genetics they
were all good-looking guys they could
all
play instruments they were good
musicians they had a good company behind
them help them right help them polish
all these songs that they wrote
and a lot of money got pumped into duran
duran and they just became a [ __ ]
blockbuster you know i mean they were an
unstoppable force i still love dorado i
mean those are still [ __ ] those are
great so they were like the beatles of
the 80s they're still great songs sorry
but these are poor kids you know yeah
and when they
do a video
they don't want to [ __ ] look like
poor kids they're no then their videos
got yachts and exotic locations and it's
hot chicks and bikinis
yeah it's like something out of a
[ __ ] gym we're all on vacation
together and yeah living the higher life
and that's that's what way they did it
and it [ __ ] worked i remember i was a
kid when that was coming out and i was
like oh that's awesome oh yeah that's so
exciting you know what i mean and
they're in james bond movies and [ __ ]
you know what the [ __ ] is i mean i kind
of you know kill that was more like 82
that was more like when rio came out
because well like when their first album
came out like 81 which is their more new
wavy one yeah which actually i'm really
a big fan of their first album the
videos from that are a lot more
low rent yeah um but i will say that
duran duran had a very good sense or
their handlers or whoever they had a
very good sense of like branding it's
like we're all gonna we're doing a theme
we're all doing like a military theme
yeah or we're doing whatever or we're
doing a new romantic thing so everyone's
gonna look like that yeah everyone's
gotta look good together yeah and we're
just like selling it and grace jones
jumped in this same [ __ ] thing too
with [ __ ] a view to a kill era
remember the view
now that was 85. so that was that was i
think that was the last single that they
put out as a five piece right before
they split off into two you had you had
duran duran they were gonna do a um
they were gonna do the movie theme
to james bond a view to a kill
that had grace jones in it as [ __ ]
christopher watkins [ __ ] sidekick
[ __ ]
christopher walken was the bad guy in it
his [ __ ]
his [ __ ] right hand man was [ __ ]
uh grace jones and she was kind of like
an assassin
and she ended up in the view to a kill
video
and then
you notice that you know grace i think
ended up making her she was making her
own stuff at that time but then about a
year or so later what was it two years
later she ended up in duran duran or
arcadia albums
yeah well no that was the same year same
year okay same year because that album
came out the same year same year then
that was 85. sir the rose came out in
85. and yeah she sang they all knew each
other she sang on the uh or katie album
on a couple of the songs yeah at least
two of them i mean election day for sure
yeah she said she was she was in
election day she was in uh
[ __ ] el diablo did she sing another
yeah she might have
i can't she did she did all the spanish
overdubbing in the beginning wasn't that
hurt
oh it might have been speaking spanish
in the beginning
isabella asked about the stranglers
uh i don't know that one oh i'm actually
i really really like the stranglers uh
golden brown probably my favorite uh
song about heroin yeah but um
they did a lot i mean peaches everybody
knows that one
uh they did a really great cover of uh
all day and all the night the king song
uh i have like a bunch of stranglers
albums but yeah i really really like the
strangler so thank you for bringing that
up
uh john smith has been fun but he has to
retire okay good night
i love a view to a kill because roger
moore was like 58 in it and everyone
just ignored it yeah i know that's
[ __ ] funny
they didn't just ignore it though
because you had you had
you had roger moore hitting [ __ ] merv
griffin and doing all the damn talk
shows the evening talk shows
daytime shot talk shows too griffin the
elevator killer yeah and they're like so
you're going to be in a nudity like but
you know what i mean and how young is
the woman they're going to be
co-starring she's young enough to be
your job yeah yeah they were they were
razzing him even back then [ __ ]
pushing 60.
and here's the thing
by today's standards [ __ ] he wasn't
even well a well-preserved 60.
you know
it was just
of the time you know that's the way it
was honestly i don't even remember like
the movie of you to a kill i know i saw
it it's not that good um
i just mostly remember like the super
awesome and entertaining like duran
duran video for the theme song yeah
where all the members of duran duran are
acting like they're spies and they're on
the eiffel tower yeah um and i kind of
dig that but i don't get video cameras
flying around i know i love it i love it
i still love that song that's a great
[ __ ] song
easily one of the best uh yeah james
bond themes i mean that song every time
i hear that [ __ ] cause they play it at
eyebar sometimes and it's like every
time i hear that opening
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm just like
[ __ ] yeah
though
yeah i'll admit that
one is getting aha did a good [ __ ] uh
the living daylight living daylight
yeah yeah and so did um garbage
which but wait which one did they do oh
[ __ ] what's the name of it [ __ ] was
it one of the uh was it one of the uh
what's his ass ones
the world is not enough oh right because
the world is not wait garbage did that
yeah garbage did that holy [ __ ] i was
like okay almost out of it during that
yeah the world is not enough
tila said people looked old back in the
60s and 70s yeah right
they did and i don't really know
entirely why that was i don't know if
it's just because diet
diet diet makeup haircuts the way they
dressed
they weren't like really taking care of
themselves and not like i am like i say
is i drink a lot yeah
they drank a lot they um
they weren't
nowadays you have a lot of [ __ ]
hormone replacement therapies and
steroids
um
so
[ __ ] um
physical fitness
okay well you looked at uh
tony basil
that's not natural that's that's [ __ ]
working out steroids and
hormone replacement you can keep you
pretty youthful looking and feeling good
without that you'll get you can get
pretty [ __ ] heavy looking [ __ ] up
but um
when you saw roger moore at 58
at least he wasn't fat
but he you know
he didn't
[Laughter]
well if you're thin you can get away
with a lot more than a fat person right
i will say that which is it's sad but
it's true even now looking at burt
reynolds watching some of burt reynolds
movies when he was getting into his 60s
i suspect he was taking some tests
wouldn't you wouldn't you
i have no idea you couldn't tell
in little a little little [ __ ]
warehouse in texas he was walking around
he didn't look a hundred percent
100 percent i'm really not
she's genuine i'm not paying that much
i'm just analyzing i'm sitting there
[ __ ] i'm worried about the story and
about like are we singing and dancing
are there movies that i can look at it's
like you know what i mean
i'm not looking fine
for i'm just saying fine that's weird
i'm looking at him and i'm going up
i think i think [ __ ] i think uh
i think i think he did was doing some
tests
he looked pretty good for his age
especially for the time
tila says aha is that the group that did
take on me yes it is yeah uh yeah they
did a james bond theme the living
daylights living daylights go look at
that one you'll immediately pick it up
living daylights uh-huh uh-huh they were
norwegian yes norwegian yeah i think
they were they were good
they were good
and some people think that they were
just like a one-hit wonder because
no they had a bunch of they uh sun
always shines on tv that was like a big
hit yeah and uh living daylights was a
big hit so they had like other big hits
too evidently their b-side stuff was
good on those albums i never had them
but they said that no the whole album is
good well our friend david who was here
earlier is a huge aha fan yeah so
i'm sure he like knows well that was the
same as soft sell soft sell evidently
all their all their [ __ ] was pretty good
on those honestly soft sell
honestly i'm a big fan of mark almond
yeah um his solo [ __ ]
it's very
uh what do i want to say it's very like
lounge don't you want me yeah which was
the cover which a lot of people don't
know
evidently everything on those albums is
good
but it's honestly mark almond his solo
[ __ ] is awesome also he also did um uh
[ __ ] uh i'll met with you right when
that was no that was no that was modern
english it was modern english yeah
modern english well i kind of feel like
they were good too though i heard all
their [ __ ] was good that hold on i told
you that yeah well i've heard that not
only you there was girls that i worked
with [ __ ] restaurants and [ __ ] i
modern english when i melt with you came
out in 82.
i bought the album which is called after
the snow
i bought it on vinyl
that whole album i mean i melt with you
is a great song i first heard i think i
heard it in valley girl which holy [ __ ]
we need to do like a [ __ ] review on
that because i love that [ __ ] movie
yeah very early nicholas cage
but tayden loved they did that too
yeah they detained love
um did uh sex no
don't don't you want me as uh humanly
that's right human leg that's right sex
dwarf sex dwarf that's right uh that's
another one i get on some i'm confused
yeah obviously but this mark almond
uh he also had a very extensive solo
career like i said he did a lot of uh
kind of lounge kind of stuff
and his voice
i love mark allman's voice
and all of the [ __ ] that he did which
was very like cabaret
oh i was so into it my favorite song
that he did is called i'm sick of you
tasting of somebody else
uh please look that up i love that
[ __ ] song so much it's like on my
phone and i listen to it like all the
time gee go listen to living daylights
from you'll see you'll see what i'm
talking about
you'll instantly go oh i think i've
heard it it's an instantly likable song
and it's also instantly recognizable as
a james bond things theme
song yeah let me see uh i saw another
[ __ ] i saw another question that i
was going to answer and then i can't now
i can't find it oh tyler says uh
that was a time when actors in their 30s
looked like they were in their 50s yeah
honestly sometimes
i see some like [ __ ] from like the 70s
and 80s
and sometimes i think that that actor is
probably like oh they got to be like
[ __ ] 35 or 40 at least and then you
find out later they were like 28 yeah
and i'm just like holy crap that's some
like [ __ ] hard living right there
you don't really see that much anymore
um they smoked a lot
i guess they drank a lot
i mean we drink a lot too but it's like
jesus christ we're not drinking every
day though that's true we don't drink
everything they drink every day i think
just a couple times a week yeah
we drink a lot but a couple times a week
um
[Music]
tell a guy says i melt with you is my
favorite happy sounding song about nukes
i don't really know if i melt with you
it's about that's about it that's about
gay love
but no seriously that whole album after
the snow
is
really really good i like every single
song on that album i listen to the [ __ ]
out of that like back i'll stop the
world and melt with you
okay
you see the difference and it's getting
better every time
all the time all the time yeah
i mean yeah yeah there's nothing you and
i won't do
this is gay sex we're talking about
i'll stop the world and i'll melt with
you
[ __ ] comment when you're coming it's
just like the world stops that's what
they're talking about it could be
heterozygous i think it's gay i think
it's gay well that might be um saying
more about you than you intend but i
both just always thought that
okay
i just kind of thought it was like
universal
well it could be you well that's what
i'm saying he's writing it as a
universality sure
but i don't think that's what he's
talking about
okay yeah
yeah well you wouldn't wouldn't you
because you know everything
[Laughter]
you you know everything that's good it's
artistic so it's good
it was straight guys i'm hitting the
booty and i'm hitting yeah
i don't get gay with that song
projection that's kind of the direction
the booty and i'm hitting the boob
you read gay things into like
interesting things that nobody else in
the world has read gabe thank you
[ __ ] [ __ ] hey
what
yeah they're attacking me
straight women doing it she's like i
don't care she's like i don't know
[Laughter]
she's like because you [ __ ] up yeah
that's why i ain't worried about you
because you [ __ ] up and you said some
like weird [ __ ]
i just think i know i never thought that
i think i met with you as gay
not everything i think it is
well like i said it's not it's not
specific enough no it's not specific
it's not specific that was what i read
into it looking at him
that's that's what i figured yeah i saw
the video he's like he never read his
it's gay to me though because like i
said in the 80s
um
honestly
in the early 80s you couldn't really
tell because it's hard to tell but well
everyone was kind of like
like i said
after punk came everyone's just kind of
like you know no one gave a [ __ ] so you
had
everybody just being like everybody had
like super feminine quote-unquote like
hair makeup [ __ ] like that so you
couldn't really tell who was gay and who
wasn't and no one really gave a crap
so
i i never really read it oh my dogs are
saying living daylights is pretty much
his favorite james bond song behind
goldfish yeah i know that's that's
that's one of the better ones although i
[ __ ] really like [ __ ] you know my
name [ __ ] i like that one from from
um
from uh
casino royale that's a good one the
alicia keys song is also super good from
um
i liked all the daniel craig songs yeah
like from the new ones i didn't like all
of them i liked the first two a lot of
some were too slow too too but you know
that's just whatever tila says pookie
said you bring it on yourself dad yeah
that's what she's saying but she's what
she says but just because she says it
doesn't mean look at her look at her
you're a cat
and you don't oh she rolls over
i point at her and says you're a kid
she's like yeah she's on her back she'll
roll down yeah she's like yes and she
won she won i'm not gonna say that
you're a cat look at you you can't
question daddy
she's like oh i absolutely love your
face this is like okay all right
she's like oh i do
can you wait can you see her move you
can't see it move i'm gonna get into the
restroom anyway
look look at her
you guys can see her right look at her
she's just back there laying like that
okay so you rolled over this is like
[ __ ] funny
um
strong78 says oh
i melt with you it's about burger king
honestly
i think they used that song in a burger
king
promotion
in
the 2000s i want to say it was fairly
recently
but
pookie uh pookie and a cat she's a
spoiled human two years old now yeah
she's actually uh she is like a spoiled
i treat her like a like a human child
she's actually
she will be
i'm trying to think how old she'll be
she'll be five
this summer she'll be five years old
we've had her since
2017. we got her in the summer of 2017
when she was just a baby i think she was
just six weeks old she was six weeks old
i think we got her and i think it was
june or july 2017. so she'll be five
this year
um
[Music]
tyler said i could have sworn it was
confirmed to be about a couple having
sex this nuclear war starts i mean if
you want to read that into it i'm trying
to like i'm thinking back to the lyrics
that i'm saying
i guess it could be i don't know that
like to me it just seems vague enough
like that you can like [ __ ] read
anything into it to me it just
every time i hear it one it reminds me
like because i had that album back then
but it also reminds me of valley girl
because
that was kind of like the big song at
the end of valley girl when
you know the valley girl like
finally like says [ __ ] it i'm going with
the punk rock guy and then that song
busts out so there's that i think that
was maybe
i want to say that was the first time i
heard it but i don't think it was i
think i'd sent her on mtv prior to that
and then
because i used to watch i mean we had
mtv i think i've brought this up before
my dad worked for cablevision
so
we got mtv
as soon as it started because we got
cable for free uh which was one of the
perks of the job
and so we got uh mtv as soon as it
started like august 1981
it came on the air and we had it
and uh i was
nine years old
almost ten
and i was glued to that [ __ ] like from
the second it started
um
because back in those days
nobody had really made any video like no
older bands really had made any videos
so a lot of the videos that they had
because they obviously they needed
content
to play
so a lot of the bands that they played
were these new wave bands that were
forward thinking enough to have made
videos
uh you know or were weird enough that
we're just kind of like well okay that's
fine we'll buy that like we need
something to show
so
you got like a really good
cross-section of like a lot of weird
like new wave and [ __ ] like that that
was like some old like a few like older
bands that were like forward thinking
stuff too but that had made some videos
and they showed those
but
mostly i remember back in the old days
it just being
almost all new wave until
a like
a year or two later when like kind of
some of the older bands like caught on
to the [ __ ] and like started making
videos for the platform
but
there was all kind of weird [ __ ] on
there back in like the early days i was
like into it
[Laughter]
okay
where was i um
and tom read gay sex yeah i kind of feel
like um see [ __ ] you [ __ ] well it
just does seem very strange that you're
like reading gay sex into like stuff
that nobody else hears that in
i'm not saying anything i'm just saying
that's uh that's a little weird it's a
little weird look a little weird no i'm
just saying to me it sounded gay
do we need to like ask something about
you
do you have something that you have to
say or no
not at all
uh camp guy was talking about peter
gabriel had some cool animation in those
early yeah yeah i think this album was
big time yeah that was um all although i
will say that was a little bit later big
time came out in 86.
yeah so that was like five years after
it said yeah yeah but i remember that it
was like a
claymation rebecca saying they didn't
get mtv until 87. holy [ __ ] yeah we had
it in
august 1981 it started and tyler says i
mean i remember what the [ __ ] modern mtv
is you lose brain cells yeah modern tv
well it's it was like totally it just
went like reality shows yeah they don't
show like music videos anymore i was
gonna make an mtv t-shirt to kind of
honor [ __ ] predator one like the one
blaine had [ __ ] he had that black mtv
shirt when the predator [ __ ] blows
and i was thinking about it and i was
like oh yeah and then i realized you
know what the average [ __ ]
wouldn't know what the hell i was
talking about they would think that i
was talking about modern day mtv
because modern day what does their logo
look like now i don't know
modern day mtv is [ __ ] [ __ ]
um is it still on it is i guess well
like i said it went well just like every
other channel it went reality tv because
that's cheaper yeah it's cheaper to
produce like reality shows the old mtv
that we grew up with was more kind of
like vh1 it was nothing but just [ __ ]
music videos it was all music videos
like all the time and then like every
now and then they'd have like a half
hour an hour where it was like a themed
show yeah and you had vj's they were
pretty good you had jj jackson on there
remember him martha quinn martha quinn
and you had [ __ ] the british dude the
blonde british dude i remember what his
name was who was to do with the big hair
and then they would yeah and that was
the very early mtv
and there was something kind of
comforting and comforting about it i
remember when it first [ __ ] came on i
was in california long beach california
we had on tv it was one of the very
first cable
services
and one of the channels on on tv was
blank and it was they were and the guide
was saying hey man it's going to be
something called mtv
could be music television
so i had it my friend jimmy and mike had
it or you know their parents had it
and [ __ ] they were going man we gotta
be on it's gonna come on in a couple
hours so i run over to [ __ ] jimmy
mike's house so we could all see it
together
we were probably i don't know
ten
maybe maybe a little bit older eleven
what year was that 81
81 okay so i've been a little bit older
i'd have been about 11. because like i
said i was
10 because that would have turned 10.
i went over there to go see it
no it would have turned nine into it
yeah so i guess it was about 11 or so i
guess that's bad i would have turned 9
that year might have been just coming up
on 12.
and uh i remember it it [ __ ] came on
it was like a little [ __ ] test
pattern and then it went and it went to
a [ __ ] ba
with the astronaut yeah astronauts
i remember that and then it was like jj
jackson they had this [ __ ] black dude
with the [ __ ] frog he's kind of
heavyset black dude i think it was him
that [ __ ] started introducing the
channel or like who's this what the [ __ ]
is going on and then he showed the very
first music video we ever saw and it was
[ __ ] it was [ __ ] video buggery
the buggles buggles the video kill the
radio star i remember it
oh yeah
the radios first video they ever played
video killed her i still love that song
in my mind or am i yeah yeah i remember
they were like what and then and it went
on for an hour it seemed like and then
the [ __ ] vj came back
it was it was cool it was really cool
we're like but what was funny is that
there weren't very many videos
that's what i was saying it's that well
a lot of star wars weren't
right uh you know forward thinking
enough yeah to be like this is a new
medium yeah so they didn't really have a
lot that's why there was so much i think
that that's why new wave got such a
foothold in the early 80s was because
those were the only videos they had to
show yeah like a lot of the bands that
were popular
you know on the radio or whatever uh
they were older and they hadn't really
got into the new video medium so they
didn't have any videos to show anybody
yeah so they were just showing videos by
like young upstarts
and so i kind of feel like that went a
long way toward like pushing the new
whole new wave thing and tina says video
kill the radio star esther in a new era
yeah
[ __ ] yeah i don't know if you've
heard it but you can find it on youtube
and watch it and listen to it it was a
good song that was their only good song
though i don't remember anything else
and i remember i don't think they did
well i mean i'm sure they did other
things but real soon after that it was
like [ __ ] like falco
and [ __ ] um
duran duran and uh
i mean duran duran were in there from
pretty much the beginning because their
first album came out in 81 yeah they
made videos for several singles off of
that album
and mtv played them because i remember
seeing them a lot of the videos that i
remember from the first couple from the
first year or two yeah like all the
duran duran videos planet earth careless
memories
um i remember two shoes nightboat yeah
adam and everybody
um i remember
oh flock of seagulls didn't know block
of sequences i ran that was 82. yeah um
and then like uh what the hell else um
i was i was thinking of something that i
you may forget
uh like i said modern english i melt
with you that was 82 second i look first
left my way that was yeah
um so i kind of feel like most of the
[ __ ] that i remember fondly because like
i said mtv came on like late in 1981
like late summer
and then so by the time 82 rolled around
they had like a good like crop of
yeah decent like new wave kind of videos
so there was like so i was like really
into that like really from the very
beginning
and then it seemed like real quick you
had [ __ ] um
[Music]
yeah and that came out that was maybe 91
81 80. that was 82.
and that was like that album was called
dare yeah i remember and that was kind
of i remember when that first appeared i
was like man that was an impressive
music video for 82.
very fancy yeah
wow that's almost like a movie
yeah
well like i said it was a new medium
because prior to that
bands had made videos but they were
usually like live performance videos
like you did have some from like the
late 60s and early 70s but they were all
like kind of like live performance with
like psychedelic [ __ ] in the background
and stuff like you had like jefferson
airplane had made some and [ __ ] like
that
so
we did see them but
once people
kind of twigged on to
the new medium they were just kind of
like oh my god we can make like a
four-minute movie out of the [ __ ] and
like duran duran we're like at the
[ __ ] forefront of that yeah uh and
that was like russell mulcahy who
actually went on to do like direct
movies and [ __ ]
but he was like directed them like they
were movies remember it was 81 or 82
though del bozio from the [ __ ]
missing person showed up and that was
[ __ ] just like a bullet right in
between your eyes that was [ __ ] that
band was made for video because you had
dale bozio if you can [ __ ] look at
her look at the missing persons go ahead
and [ __ ] google [ __ ] she was words is
my favorite yeah what are words for when
nobody's walking in l.a yeah walking in
l.a was the first first thing that i
remember from her she was kind of i like
words words is a good song she was kind
of like lady gaga just out of the blue
yeah very pre-lady guy yeah and um
she was a penthouse
pet so she was [ __ ] hot as [ __ ]
and
the whole
she ever i didn't know it at the time
but
i've seen interviews with her [ __ ]
more recent times she hated that music
the whole band was kind of an artifice
it kind of bums me out actually
because i i really liked a lot of their
[ __ ] yeah she hated that music the whole
band was an artificial construct to make
a bunch of money
through youtube or through um not
youtube yeah we're in youtube
through mtv
but now the missing persons were [ __ ]
the visuality of it it was almost kind
of like
this
semi-nude chick with [ __ ]
solar [ __ ] panels for a mini skirt
yeah [ __ ] futuristic and [ __ ] very
sci-fi clear [ __ ]
clear [ __ ] cups over her [ __ ]
teddies and [ __ ] [ __ ] white hair out
like this and
blue [ __ ] she was like lady gaga is a
copy of that if you ask me dale bozio
i mean
lady gaga like has taken a lot of
influence from
early 80s new wave
uh
you know madonna obviously
yeah you know but honestly i think of
like madonna like ripped off a lot of
stuff from like 80s new wave too so
people that were just like kind of one
or two hit wonders yeah
and but and like i said i'm not [ __ ]
on madonna because honestly when madonna
first came onto the scene
because uh she kind of came up as a club
kid and she kind of came up on the club
scene like particularly the gay club
scene
um
you know she had kind of like a cool
look about her
she looked kind of not punk rock but she
looked kind of like
alternative i guess yeah she had a
little bit of a punk rock look to her
yeah so a lot of her like old [ __ ] i
kind of like that and honestly some of
her songs i still like i still like into
the groove yeah that's a great [ __ ]
song rebecca said that it's [ __ ] she
looks like she came out of blade runner
yeah she did she just saying that woman
sounds like a normal looking person in
berkeley i i think she's talking about
dale bozia
you talking about you talking about um
missing persons right
i would think wait where are you looking
at dinner at the bottom
uh great makeup oh they're talking about
uh the thriller the thriller okay
thrillability they're talking about the
thriller video yeah which was uh which
was directed by john landis yeah okay
thriller thriller was not the first
michael jackson video that we saw though
first one i saw was billie jean billie
jean first one i saw was billy jeans not
my love with the light upside down just
a chair
who said i am the one
a chair the chair yeah
cause the chair is not my son
yeah that's what i thought he was saying
[Laughter]
did you really think he was saying yeah
i thought he was saying like wait did
somebody confirm
what's going on
i was wondering how a [ __ ] could
be related to a chair but i was thinking
like well this [ __ ] happens you know i
mean you're just sitting in china you
were just kind of like wow like he'd
give birth to a chair
[Music]
i couldn't understand i hate women i was
young you know i
thought it might be possible
sure chair
the chair is not mine this is my son the
chair yeah yeah yeah
that was a great video i need to like i
need to make that another [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's like this all the time well
this is what happens like you give me
these mental images
and then i can't get past it because now
all i'm thinking of
is like this hugely pregnant woman and
like a chair coming out of that vagina
that's what i was thinking like this but
and like a nice comfortable chair like
maybe a lazy boy
like come down you see i was white so
you know i'm like freaking i'm like
chair chairs in the chair
yeah okay all right the chair is not as
i have to say share
of this chair yeah
holy [ __ ] i got you back him jake
that chair is not your son
you were not related to that chair i was
just trying to
i was young you know oh
i'm gonna say didn't okay didn't beat it
come out before thriller yeah
i feel like and i could be remembering
this wrong it was a long time ago
for sure i saw billie jean that was the
first michael jackson video i saw for
sure yeah
pretty sure i saw
um
beat it
before a thriller
am i remembering that wrong
or no
pretty sure i thought beat it yeah i
think maybe
i'm trying to i remember billie jean
being the first
well i know yeah that was yeah that was
the i know that was the first t you
don't understand you don't understand
what it was like
you don't understand what it's like back
then you're a little kid you're watching
television it's color okay but it's it's
not
it's it's [ __ ] not hd okay it's
cathode ray tube television
you're up in california somewhere down
in vista with your aunt lois at you at
lois's house
and [ __ ] you're seeing
michael jackson doing
[ __ ] billie jean and it's like of
in those days it was like a
like a [ __ ] hollywood production
movie it's a god i still like that song
yeah you're like damn it was like they
were they did not spend that kind of
money in music videos they only spent
that kind of money in movies
so you you knew that it had her it had
arrived
yeah it's like this [ __ ] arrived sure
right
yeah whoa
and um mj was [ __ ] good man he was
real good
i grew up listening to him
now i never really bought any of his
albums because you didn't have to the
ship was on the radio [ __ ] 24 7. you
didn't have to buy anything from the
dude
the only thing i ever did was uh i guess
it was around 86. i rented that
what was that moon raker no what was the
name of that [ __ ] viney mccall dad
[ __ ]
walker moonraker [ __ ] movie was that
terrible james bond yeah yeah yeah where
roger moore
took his old ass to the moon to the moon
didn't he
he had to stop him from killing
everybody with a [ __ ] virus man
all right
right
he's better when it's floating are you
gonna float and [ __ ] pussy's better
when it's floating you're gonna do some
zero g [ __ ] like that that's what he's
doing i kind of feel like that's that
when you're 68 that's you need [ __ ]
zero g action you're like this you're
ripping that [ __ ] around like that you
like
flying that's what he's doing so i feel
like that's probably not the case you're
not going to get like any friction or
any kind of like there's no gravity
solid imaginary it's all imaginable okay
so i'm like a water bed it's like a
water bed but
that's okay that was the thinking back
then all right
all right i gotta pee you're killing me
i'm not kidding
but anyway i saw
uh moonwalker
all right i rented it
from see she's gotta go take a leak
so i went and saw mill walker i i didn't
go and see it i went and rented it and i
brought it back
at the time i think i was i was in high
school in brazil at the time
and [ __ ]
that vhs tape
was kind of like the best thing going of
that year and up until that time
it was kind of like a video album
i think it has seven or eight songs on
it maybe a little bit more and it was
kind of had a
story that kind of threaded them all
through there together
and i really enjoyed it and i was into
metal at the time i wasn't into [ __ ]
michael jackson music i was just
wanting to read it because it was a
it was a cultural thing at the time
everybody else was seeing it and i was
like well you know i did like this song
and did like that song and i'm just
gonna see what let's go see what it's
about my [ __ ] rent it
rented it
it was great
it was great you had the claymation
stuff
you had uh
stories you had the
at the end [ __ ] mj shows up as a
[ __ ] transformer
and blows [ __ ] up you know what i mean
you know about that did you
michael jackson shows up as a robot all
right
okay now was this the one that they
showed at epcot or no am i thinking of
something they should have showed it at
epcot if they didn't i don't know but he
shows up a lot of stuff happened to it i
didn't really
look him back on it you know what i mean
[ __ ] with what happened to him later
somebody's just kind of suspicious she
did have some young young boys in there
there were some young white boys in the
movie and i'm not sure exactly what the
relationships were
between this and and penises and [ __ ] i
don't really [ __ ] know okay what was
the relationship between them and
penises
could have i don't know the penises were
over here just hovering about white boys
over here
money over here
paris over here
all happening in california
because be it from california i don't
trust them [ __ ]
them [ __ ] pimping [ __ ] that they
got down there i don't get it
but no i don't get it i don't get it
i don't understand it i wasn't there so
i'm not going to make any accusations
thank you i'm not going to make it it's
all a legend don't get us all allegedly
don't get a sued now [ __ ] that's why
i say allegedly all the time allegedly
now
razor fist did a whole show on this [ __ ]
you can look at his channel i like that
razer fist he's good
and he's a metal guy and he looked into
this [ __ ] and he says that he does not
believe that [ __ ] anything happened
with mg he thought mj was set up but he
did think that maybe mj was was very
weird
but he didn't think clearly yeah very
weird but he didn't think that dude was
acting on anything i mean i don't know i
wasn't there i'm kind of on the fence
about it there's a bunch of other [ __ ]
and when he [ __ ] tells it in the the
history
it could have been that
that predatory people were setting him
up
to take his money knowing that he had
some weaknesses
but there's no evidence that he did
anything
i mean like i said it's
it's weird because there's like not a
lot i don't know it looks bad it looked
bad but there's not a lot of evidence
but honestly i'm really like if you're
into like conspiracy theories like
people were setting it up said setting
him up i kind of feel like you need more
evidence for that because that's like a
little bit more unbelievable it's just
let me taste it but let me tell you
something oh he's going to tell me
something i'm going to tell jenny's
stuff he's going to mansplain something
i'm going to explain some [ __ ] he's got
a thomas blade how about tom's playing
some [ __ ]
thomas played tm okay
how old was michael j mj when all this
[ __ ] went down his story he was like 30
something i don't know
i'll tell you one thing if i was a
single male in my 30s and i had a
[ __ ] all this damn fame and money i
would not have
a house
with an amusement park out front of it
and a bunch of stuff yeah but you're not
him though the statues everybody's
brother tom braun statues of all these
you would just have
a bunch of women like laying and saying
it would look like a so you could walk
on a carpet of dickies thank you there
you go that's what you would have i
think most guys would be like that i
know you i would never have any titties
i would never have
a gigantic sprawling uh [ __ ] compound
of [ __ ] amusement parks like i said
that does seem very very sketchy [ __ ]
video arcades
and hundreds and hundreds of bronze
statues of little [ __ ] skinny peter
pan looking little white boys everywhere
drinking out of water with their cute
little booties up in the air drinking
about a while it's just no
no
most humans would be like yeah that's
that's weird no it's too many little
[ __ ] things
but
[Music]
the thing about him was that he had
problems yeah and that maybe he never
progressed beyond childhood yeah i don't
know i don't i i'm not coming down on
either side of it because i don't really
i wasn't there i don't really know how
it's like it looks bad i'm gonna say
like i'm gonna lean on the side of like
it being like yeah there's probably some
sketchy [ __ ] going on because it doesn't
look too good
but maybe he was just some weirdo that
like didn't really [ __ ] know the
difference you know i didn't say this is
the funniest ever hugo says and then
weirdo yankovic came and stole the show
yeah yeah yeah uh and tila says i love
weirdos parody of bad by aj yeah yeah it
was called fat and it was all about food
yeah uh you know because i'm fat and
yeah ham on whole wheat yeah hit my
whole all right yeah yeah i have that
album somewhere it's
sounds great right about now
it does actually but um but the thing is
those were busting on mj
and there was a lot to bust on mj but um
no those albums were very good very
solid he was not
innovative
i would say
prince was innovative yeah uh michael
jackson was not innovative but he could
but he was like the best at that
for a while michael jackson could
see what was popular and jump in there
and [ __ ] give you a product
that would fit into the to the gestalt
and the zeitgeist of the time
um he he could put on a really good show
would michael jackson have stood the
test of time no
no prince would but not michael jackson
stop it
you just write i'm looking at you and
you're looking don't look guilty just
don't do it okay she's like you can't
stop yeah you're right
she swallowed real hard and look nice
you go back to it okay
um
no daddy yells at me and then i just
keep on doing it nothing happens
my i think michael jackson's biggest
strength was that he could dance
that was even more than the singing i
think he could dance well he was a good
performer yeah he's a good performer uh
yeah but i'm still gonna when you talk
about
when you talk about
black power houses i'm gonna give it the
[ __ ] prince
i think most people would yeah i think
prince could play instruments and he was
more innovative and prince was sexy uh
there's just nothing really sexy about
me yeah michael jackson not so much no
um yeah but prince was like totally hot
yeah and i kind of feel like everybody
male female whatever gender you are
whatever race you are or whatever
whatever when i was a kid they had white
glasses everybody had [ __ ] prince that's
what i mean okay they're not trying to
would you like to [ __ ] prince yeah sure
yeah like back in the year they're not
trying to [ __ ] everybody they're trying
to [ __ ] prince
i mean if they said no
then people are gonna like check on you
well listen to his lyrics something's
the matter listen to the lyrics listen
listen to prince's lyrics and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] the way he's saying this [ __ ]
was sexual
okay
um he was a skinny little dude he'd
[ __ ] get on a damn album cover
[ __ ] [ __ ] semi nude and [ __ ]
[ __ ] he could he's riding his
motorcycle make a move making movies and
his hair and [ __ ] and his [ __ ]
clothes
he was cooler than michael jackson in a
lot of ways well yeah you know i mean to
me like growing up at the time it's like
michael jackson was like fine like you
understood that that was like good music
but wasn't sexy it was yeah it and it
was very mainstream yeah um
you understood that prince was way
cooler like even back in the 80s
uh so there was that prince had a dirty
side
yeah that's what i mean it was like it
was dirty so like everybody was like way
more into that
right
uh
when they hit prince was in innovating
is also talking about the jeopardy
parody that weird al did
that is a song i don't know if you know
the original song that that came from
yeah but it was a song called jeopardy
by greg kinn
which was like i used to really really
dig that
uh song and that video back in the old
days it's like super cheap by today's
standards saying [ __ ] another try to
hook up with michael jackson too those
are freaky girls regular women were
trying to hook up with [ __ ] those
were freaky those are freaky girls
regular women were trying to [ __ ]
hook up with friends
yeah prince had a lot wider appeal
prince was understandable
you could understand what prince was
about it's hard to understand what
michael jackson was about maybe some
women might be kind of [ __ ]
enthralled by that mystified
but now there's something kind of not
right about michael jackson's image i'm
just saying man
i don't want to make any accusations but
there's just something strange about
that i mean the thing about it is that
like like look i'm a weirdo and it's
like i've been a weirdo my whole [ __ ]
life but even i was just kind of like
prince would be who you'd want to hang
out with yeah
i would much rather hang out with
brandon right
michael jackson always seemed like a
little weird to me yeah
he well he's weird because he's like
childlike yeah which
like i said i'm not into children so i
don't really want to hang out with
children and he kind of always seemed
like that
so anyway what i was saying was that uh
you don't have to be cool i can't do
that [ __ ] voice man forget to make
fun of me if i try to make that voice
you already did it though yeah so
he could sing man
yeah i know
it's weird because i appreciate him now
more than i did in the 80s i feel like
well because we were sick of it we're
being bombarded by it that's what i mean
i kind of feel like a lot of stuff took
that [ __ ] for granted yeah you did yeah
i mean honestly during the 80s like i
said i was listening to [ __ ] bauhaus
and alien sex queen and like the smiths
and depatch mode and [ __ ] like that and
the cure
and so yeah [ __ ] that was like on the
radio yeah like prince and stuff or
madonna i was just kind of like man i
like some of like madonna's older [ __ ]
and princess older [ __ ]
but then like as time went on i was just
kind of like nope not having it but like
as i get older yeah you look at you go
like oh that [ __ ] was good man when you
hear it you're like
that was a good [ __ ] song i didn't
like it at the time but i like it like
well like i said we were being bombarded
with it but yeah it was ubiquitous so
you kind of like got sick of it because
it was like on the radio like prince was
on the radio all the time and everybody
knew it right everybody everybody knew
it so it was just kind of like
yeah you kind of got sick of it but now
that like 20 30 40 years have gone by
and like you
don't hear it every day you can like
hear it with
fresh ears i guess so you can like hear
it
anew and it actually is a good song
honestly like even some [ __ ] that i
hated back in the 80s like [ __ ] [ __ ]
by like genesis and [ __ ] like that like
i don't love it i wouldn't buy it but if
i hear it i'm like ah that's all right
yeah see t got it right if you go on a
date with mj you're gonna go to disney
you're gonna watch movies go to a date
with prince you're not you're not gonna
come back home that's right
he's thinking of [ __ ] rick james
oh rick james was maybe yeah rick james
was a bad dude him and his girlfriend
were [ __ ] like kind of kidnapping
other women
and [ __ ] threatened them with
cigarette lighters
no rick james said that that's rick
james yeah but who knows who knows uh
how true that is rick james was a bad
[ __ ] but he was also pretty cool
and he was a bad drug addict i mean it
was just kind of hard to understand
i don't know i i i would have had fun
hanging out with rick james i think but
he would have i've seen i've seen
probably you would have got arrested i
got arrested
i've seen videotapes of rick james i'm
laughing my ass off and said yeah i'd
have fun with rick james but we'd get in
a lot of trouble and he'd probably get
on my nerves after after a while
because rick james was was one of those
[ __ ] that couldn't shut up he
was constantly [ __ ] talking
and he would try to get laid just on the
back of him being rick james instead of
just [ __ ] being a man trying to yeah
like i'm rick james i'm rick james [ __ ]
go ahead and come into this and then i
mean there's a reason there's a reason
why
there's a reason i became a joke shut
the [ __ ] up and just be yourself and get
laid shut the we know you're rick james
shut the [ __ ] up played naturally just
get right but unnatural on the natural
nobody likes the do you know who i am
yeah look i'm rick james i got these
albums come on [ __ ] suck my dick
because i'm rick james anybody that says
do you know who i am yeah no
automatically it's like uh
yes and we hate you say bye but yeah he
had drug problems he died
um
you know
but evidently he did kind of him and his
girlfriend kidnapped another girl
yeah but nobody knows what that
if
she might have made a lot of that up
you know well i don't know i'm not gonna
go that far i don't know i don't know
that much about it so i don't really it
was all between rockheads
they were all rockets i mean
[ __ ] happens between crackheads
uh
i think crack had
was the main factor more than anything
else
he got acquitted to that [ __ ] whatever
it was
i mean that doesn't mean he didn't do it
it's just that there wasn't enough
evidence yeah it was all sketchy the
girl was sketchy too they just from what
i understand we might have do the show
on that maybe we got to do a show on
this we should we probably should yeah
rick james some people said we should do
a whole show about michaels we haven't
we haven't done michael jackson's
channel michael jackson we've talked
about it a few times yeah
what's funny is you know as old as we
are we need to start talking about
people that [ __ ] were around when we
were kids so we can [ __ ] cast that
[ __ ] in stone to leave behind to future
generations so they could [ __ ] go
back and say what did old [ __ ]
think of [ __ ] michael jackson what
really happened y'all were there tell us
you know because because we were there
at the time listening to it in the in
real time in the media in real time what
that was like
but even now like even given this um i
mean now that it's this many years later
i still don't really know like like i
said i wasn't there and i hate to like
i hate to like jump to conclusions i
don't it's it's a bad thing to like get
involved in because it's like i don't
want to like [ __ ]
jump to his defense because he might
have been like a [ __ ] perv yeah and i
don't necessarily want to like cast
aspersions on like the kids or the
parents that were like yeah accusing him
of [ __ ] because you know you you don't
want to get into a thing where it's like
you're just distrusting dragons is in
there going no she had proof she had
bruises and everything
but yeah that doesn't mean a whole lot
that'd be kind of like [ __ ] kind of
things that happened between
[ __ ] um sid vicious and nancy
uh they were [ __ ] punk rockers they
were rough on each other
even
part of being a punk rocker in that
culture was to rough a [ __ ] up
you know what i mean and i had park rock
girlfriends they were like that made
[ __ ] it was love to rough you up a
little bit it's kind of like a bdsm type
thing
now with [ __ ]
with rick james and his girlfriend these
are crackheads
they were probably they may have been
roughing her up i don't know jenny
hasn't done a full analysis yet i just
just started commenting yeah just based
on what i remember there was a lot of
stuff that was up in the air
she probably could have run but she
wasn't running because there was a bunch
of crack involved
but uh
weird [ __ ] happened back in those days
well where should happens this happens
everywhere all the time always
this is all between scenesters and
famous people
and uh they're not necessarily super
intelligent you know they got a lot of
money and drug problems and they're
famous
and um
yeah they get out of hand
it doesn't necessarily mean it's [ __ ]
100
mean-spirited or that it's 100 percent
non-consensual
i mean uh you just have to see what
happens you know man if i can
did she try to get away or
did she say yeah i want to get away but
i really can't get away because this is
a source of crack
i don't you know it's just
i don't know all the details from what i
remember is that
it was all sketchy when it came to
when it came to rick james and that
situation with that one girl and his
girlfriend
i remember that evidently that they
burned her with a cigarette lighter out
of a damn car
but i don't know the [ __ ] details
about that
did he just [ __ ] go [ __ ] like that
or did he hold it on her and he'll cook
her with it how many how you know what
what was the deal i mean these people
are
[ __ ]
high all the time
you know and fighting
tyler says even if he wasn't a pedo
there was some clear weird mental stuff
going on there oh i agree with mj yeah
yeah i mean he very obviously had some
issues
understandably um he had like a really
weird
upbringing
what was weird about mj is that there
was a lot of a lot about him back in the
time that was kind of what back in those
days would have been kind of goth
friendly
he would have
he was ripping off the goth subculture
quite a bit a lot of stuff he was
wearing he was detected with stuff that
he was getting from us
and he was kind of he was not a normal
guy he was like something out of the
damn underworld you know what i mean he
was from a subculture but he was the
leader of his own little subculture
there wasn't a bigger part of it he was
constantly trying to take things that
were happening what he called on the
street and bringing that into the mid to
the mainstream
and on the bad album he's trying to
bring goth mainstream
the clothes that he's wearing is
same clothes that the guys from bauhaus
were wearing
well several like a decade earlier yeah
like a decade
[Laughter]
yeah
holy parrish of doom says underground
metal vedic frost slayer venom yeah dead
kennedys and crowmags
uh 80s had fantastic underground music
it did i agree kennedy's were punk
though not metal yeah
man i [ __ ] loved the dickens yeah
they were good i saw the kermit that
would be awesome yeah i saw the
criminals live uh in daytona beach
involved a lot of people didn't know
jello was gay
i didn't know that he was gay
yeah
um i don't know if he ever formally came
out or anything like that but it was
just something that wasn't ever
discussed i guess it wasn't like i i
think that he thought that it wasn't
really
relevant i think it was relevant he
should have said something about it but
it was a heavens he would have been
ahead of his time well he said something
about it later but yeah yeah um
but uh because i think that might have
added something to it
i had that plastic surgery disasters out
i [ __ ] loved it
the [ __ ] right i love all their [ __ ]
yeah great album
i have that somewhere too
that's why one of the things is you know
i have a lot of respect for rob halford
being a jewish priest fan rob came out
rob came out early you just had to pay
attention to the lyrics he came out on
the cen after scent album
on the [ __ ] out on the song [ __ ]
raw deal we talked about going to fire
island down we he made it he made the
spike at nine o'clock on a saturday all
eyes were on him as he walked into the
bar
that's right
they had all these stealing leather
dudes the [ __ ]
cops leather cops playing rough stuff
yeah hell yeah he's taught you tell
anybody he's telling you that he was gay
i was listening to that as a kid i was
like wait a minute what no really i was
kind of like i couldn't but like yeah
that's what it was
there was no
there was no coming out back in the very
early ages well i kind of feel like
there wasn't a framework there wasn't a
framework for it it's like you could
talk about it and like if you were kind
of vague enough right then people who
were gay that like realize that thing
they're like holy [ __ ] they're talking
to me yeah and like that was like really
empowering but if you weren't
into it then you were just kind of like
okay whatever you didn't like nobody was
talking about you didn't think about it
right so i kind of feel like there was a
lot of that [ __ ] going on
but
jelly biafra i kind of feel like he
maybe i don't really know but i kind of
feel like he maybe thought
that that wasn't really their focus like
the band's focus so maybe he thought it
would be distracting i don't really know
i don't know yeah t says we should have
a show on infamous celebs and rick james
wrote a book i'm on amazon right now put
it in my basket
yeah oh my god it's probably a good book
i i actually would would like to read
yeah
sure
uh rebecca says uh with all criminality
can't judge a book by its cover uh like
bill cosby yeah everyone's kind of
surprised about that
uh tyler says party all the time is
[ __ ] hilarious yeah murphy trying to
beat james
all the time oh yeah put the boogie in
your butt that's what's going to put a
telephone on your butt
yeah it's like what are you putting my
butt you put anything in your butt
that's what [ __ ] michael
i'm just saying what is it that you're
putting in my butt everybody i have
everything
according to that song everything goes
in your book
that's
kenny murphy was [ __ ] hilarious i'm
putting an entire cake in your butt i'm
just putting the empire state building
in your butt i'm putting like all of
these things man these [ __ ] young
folks
these [ __ ] young folks
go go look at boogie in your book okay
boogie in your butt [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] eddie murphy talking about all
the things he's gonna put in your ass
okay
it's [ __ ] funny man it's a funny song
okay it was good the [ __ ] was on the
radio
eddie murphy a lot of people [ __ ]
don't understand especially you young
[ __ ] you don't understand you [ __ ]
young [ __ ] don't understand that
eddie murphy was [ __ ] huge huge
when i was a kid well he was a cultural
huge you're talking about as big as tom
cruise that's how big he was
okay
his movie started to suffer over time
uh overexposure had a lot to do with it
him trying to go mainstream family
comedy didn't work
eddie murphy had to be [ __ ] edgy yeah
i didn't love that it didn't work when
he went mainstream it's because he
bought his own production company he
tried to do what that dude
did with the [ __ ]
the media guy the medea guy yeah which i
like medea movies i got two of them
[ __ ] and we've seen some of them in
the theaters i [ __ ] but when i watch
medina the medea funeral movie yeah when
i'm watching medea though it's it's
basically i'm like this is basically
what eddie murphy tyler perry tyler
perry and i was watching tyler
it's kind of like what eddie was doing
yeah you know it's like i'm going to
dress up in all these outrageous yeah
i'm going to put on a fat suit and i'm
going to be in dragon i'm going to play
like five different characters i mean
eddie murphy was doing that you better
meet him when he did that yeah he
already did but tyler perry was made a
good [ __ ] live and he got rich doing
that on his own with that independently
without anybody
telling him what to do so i i respected
that but uh no medea [ __ ] and some
people when you watch that [ __ ] yeah
yeah
says oh god tyler perry i can't rock
with that one yeah well i saw the
funeral one and it was like parts that
were kind of funny but like i've seen
parts of some of his other movies
like in doctor's offices and whatnot
well like if they were playing the tv
and it's just like
i don't know it's kind of like the
entertainment equivalent of going to get
some chicken wings
it's like chicken wings it's [ __ ] the
shit's available pretty much anywhere
it's just such it's low-hanging really
low hanging fruit slow hanging but i
still enjoyed it you know what i mean
the idea is escapism when you're talking
about entertainment you just watch it
and just laugh you know
taylor says halloween
medea is all right i guess but no
okay well see i've only seen some i've
only seen a few of those movies i could
see that probably that might suffer from
the same thing that happened to
eddie murphy is overexposure
because i looked at the catalog he's got
a lot of that [ __ ] some of the shits
well tyler perry has his own production
company he's very very into
he's and it's weird because i've only
seen a couple of them but it's like his
whole thing
is like we have to make this kind of
like lowbrow humor but also super
christian yeah that was weird which
the tone of it really is very jarring to
me
like i don't think those two things go
together i don't really like low brow
humor generally
um it can't be done well i'm not saying
like i'm averse to it or anything but
a lot of it like i said it's very low
hanging fruit it's very obvious you can
see like a lot of the jokes coming from
like a long time away i had fun with it
but yeah they're not reading into it too
much well no but i'm just saying that
yeah but like people that know anything
about comedy it's like yeah i've already
seen this joke done better like 30 years
ago you know it's so there's that kind
of thing and the weird like christian
overlay that it has on it it's just like
really like sucks any of the humor that
it has i like out for me i don't know
it's just like a weird tonal
uh what's the opposite of synergy it's
like it's just like a weird like tonal
uh
i don't know it's just like very very
like uh
just i don't i don't know what the word
i'm trying to think of but it's like
really really [ __ ] [ __ ] up
um let me see uh
tyler perry was for a weird race of
southwest
yeah and yeah that's actually a good
point mary kylie says it's kind of a
rip-off of carol burnett's mama skits
yeah um it's kind of that whole thing i
feel like that's maybe a little bit of a
subculture i guess but yeah like back in
the day
on the carol burnett show or she was
when she was doing kara burnett show and
then they did mama's family later on i
kind of feel like there's a whole like
weird subculture of
people putting on
i'm gonna put on like a fat suit and
like old lady makeup
and that's gonna be like
funny it's like it was funny when carol
burnett did it
and it was
less funny when eddie murphy did it but
funnier than when tyler perry did it so
let's say that i only saw two or three
of his movies and i laughed through all
three of two or three of them
that's you know i i didn't read twitch i
thought they were funny
but
then again what makes me laugh sometimes
is like
comfort humor and it to me it was just
kind of comforting to hear when i you
know i understood the humor and it was
just yeah just laughing you know
now there's some [ __ ] on on um there's a
lot of them on amazon
some of them are like live
productions on a stage
yeah yeah yeah i just seen those i
haven't seen those i've only seen like a
couple of them some of the movies i
think started out as stage productions
okay i'm not mistaken yeah
i mean like props to him he started like
a whole [ __ ]
production company he's made like 40
bajillion dollars doing that [ __ ] like
carving his own niche yeah which is hard
to do he's got his own characters and
stuff and people want to see him over
and over again which yeah like i said
that's not that's cool i'm not [ __ ]
on it it's just it's not for me yeah um
because like i said a lot of the jokes
in it are just very i mean to me they
seem very stale it seemed like like [ __ ]
that my grandparents were laughing at
um you know what i made so it's just
kind of like yeah i've seen like other
comedians do that like 40 years ago and
it was funnier but that's kind of why it
just seems very like old
people
tina santana's media movies [ __ ]
everything
the ones that i saw were funny i only
saw three of them i did laugh a few
times at that like funeral one but like
i like any kind of like dark humor that
has to do with like making fun of like
dead people that like that's funny to me
i don't know why but like yeah so i did
think that was funny but some of the
other ones i can't remember the one that
i saw i was in like a [ __ ] doctor's
office one time and inexplicably they
had a medea movie i don't know which one
it was because there's a million
they had that playing in the waiting
room
and so i was like watching that because
i had to wait forever and i was just
kind of like watching it and i was just
kind of like it wasn't it wasn't um kind
of like the contact shame that i had
when i was watching cool as ice it
wasn't that cringy
but
i was cringing a little bit like
nonetheless we saw one we saw one at amc
on [ __ ] yeah it was the funeral one
the funeral one i laughed and do it i
thought it was funny i was i was parts
of it were fine i thought it was funny
but like i said i think part i think the
reason that i thought that was funny was
because it was all like death-centered
humor which i usually think is hilarious
because i i don't i don't know i like
like a lot of cops i pulled her over and
she didn't want to [ __ ] remember that
she didn't want to come quietly to the
cops she was going to pull over
that's looking funny
tyler says i think tyler perry is a good
guy but as a director he is so so so so
bad
he's just making product
i mean it's working like i said i'm not
[ __ ] on it because obviously like
people want to see that yeah so he's got
his own who am i to say that it's like
not any good if you want to see that
then that's like got his own following i
don't think a lot of it is funny but
they want to see those characters over
and over i think it's funny then it's
enough for him to make to buy a house
that's cool yeah like i said who am i to
say that's like you think that's fine
then watch it
i wouldn't like other people telling me
like [ __ ] i think it's funny it's not
funny so
i'm not i'm not [ __ ] you look at
this show i'm just like we're
doing this show you know
that's what i'm saying and like i said
you know i would never tell anybody look
this show isn't for everybody yeah
obviously
because we only have less than 12 000
subscribers although i will say
that
i kind of feel bad about that sometimes
because i kind of feel like well we
should probably have more subscribers
but
i will note that a lot of horror
channels that i really like a lot of
channels that i really like
have
significantly less subscribers than we
have
particularly horoscope because uh
youtube is kind of like uh favoring
corporate sponsorship first so i mean if
you like horror [ __ ] you're kind of like
marginalized anyway
yeah what we're talking about and then
uh there's a lot of
suppression going on in the algorithms
now i will note that there's a couple
horror channels and a couple of true
crime channels that have way more
subscribers than us yeah
but
a lot of the ones that i like better
than that stuff
well i don't know like not necessarily
yeah um we do go off topic a lot i will
say that um
[Music]
but i drink a lot on this show and we
drink a lot yeah but there's other ones
like that too yeah that have i don't
know like i don't really know
i don't know if there's an answer to it
really i was thinking about it earlier
because i was watching honestly one of
my favorite horror channels
on youtube
is uh grumpy andrew grumpy andrew's
horror house g-a-h-h
uh who's just like this british dude and
he talks about like [ __ ] horror
movies and he loves old [ __ ] like he
loves hammer movies he loves dario
argento he loves all that stuff and i
love him and he's like so cool i think
he only has
maybe three or four thousand subscribers
maybe well maybe more but he has i think
less than us
but
he's one of my favorite guys and he just
kind of like sits in front of he doesn't
have a you know he's very articulate
and he's very uh he knows a lot about
horror movies but
he's not like super polished it's not
like super
you know edited cool or anything like
that it's just like a dude that's really
passionate about movies like talking
about movies and i don't know i i kind
of feel like
it's kind of hit or miss really
like what gets what was that on the door
oh cat can open the door
i was like what was that noise she was
like man i'll be [ __ ] laying up in
the [ __ ] bedroom
i have to go out and [ __ ] i got
because i'm always listening i always
have [ __ ] little earphone in i have
to get up go take a leak
come back into bed put the earphone in
and try to fall back asleep and i hear
that [ __ ] cat opening the cupboards
yeah it's creepy when you think about it
well it's not creepy to me because i
know that that's what that is that cat
can open the cupboard and slam the
cupboards yeah and and then she'll open
another one and she thinks something is
cool in there that's why yeah
she doesn't like any closed door yeah
she thinks this is closed because
there's something awesome though so i
gotta open it right so i have to open it
and make sure
there might be like some meat sticks or
brushes or something like that in there
that i really need right now um and
honestly sometimes i'll be
yeah we're talking about yeah we're
talking about um sometimes i'm working
in here and like i hear
pull and then i look over and she's like
at her little head
stuck in that she's got a little pot
like that like what's in here there's
nothing in there it's just it's coffee
and like sweet and low yeah
reach in there and open up a [ __ ]
cupboard and open it up and then [ __ ]
slam it boom
nothing in there [ __ ] that it's [ __ ]
hilarious
i'll be in bed going to man what if
that's a ghost
well see that's the thing you don't have
to worry
if you hear noises in the middle of the
night
it's not a ghost yeah it's her
she's for as small as she is yeah she's
a tiny little cat she weighs maybe 10
pounds
she can make more noise
than a [ __ ] full-size person yeah
i've never heard such a racket from such
a tiny little a tiny little being
she makes so much [ __ ] noise
um louis showed up what's up louie
well hey
um
tila says like i always say i found tom
and jenny looking for blacula reviews
and theirs is the best one on youtube
yeah yeah yeah i was talking to trey
earlier today trey simmons who's one of
our uh regulars
i don't know if he's here tonight but he
messages me a lot i talk to him a lot on
youtube and i told him earlier i was
kind of like look i was like i feel like
we maybe put up too much content
maybe because not only do we have we do
two live streams a week we do
we record a movie review once a week we
do live matinee like movie reviews
three or four times a week and then i do
two movie reviews a week and a book
review
so i have something going up every week
and also i put up cat videos
um
and i was kind of like i feel like is
that too much yeah
and he was like i don't think it is
because he's like i love you guys
and he's like i just really like the the
idea that there's so much like content
that i can like
watch whenever i want and it's like all
this because honestly
this is this is [ __ ] up
i was thinking today because i had a
message that like somebody recommended a
movie to me and i was just like oh [ __ ]
i gotta get around to doing that
and so many people have recommended
movies to me i'm just like man i can't
doing two movie reviews in one book
review i can't keep up with all the [ __ ]
and then i was like looking through
shutter and amazon prime and hulu and
toby and everything and i was seeing all
these movies and i'm like oh [ __ ] i
gotta oh i haven't reviewed that one yet
oh [ __ ] i gotta watch that one again and
i was like holy crap i'm never gonna
like live long enough to review all of
these and then i was just like maybe i
should just start doing like extra movie
reviews
and posting them just like whenever and
then i'm like am i crazy
holy crap i'm already like working
how many hours a day
i don't know 12 hours a day something
like that well i usually get up at like
between seven and eight
and start working
and uh then i usually stop about six or
seven at night so about like i don't
know 10 11 12 hours a day and i'm
already doing that like every day
and i was like now i'm thinking maybe i
should do more videos maybe that's maybe
it's not enough but
i don't know i just feel like i'm behind
there's so many movies we haven't done
that i feel like i should have done
i don't know man and then like there's
new [ __ ] coming out and everybody's like
look i haven't been to the theater we
haven't been in the theater to see the
batman we haven't been to the theater to
see x i need to see that the new thai
west movie i haven't seen that yet so
we're like behind
we're behind yeah
this is my life i feel like i'm
constantly behind it's going to be all
right
is it this could be alright
yeah um
there's another good show you might want
to look at she was looking at uh she
found us through [ __ ] watching black
live videos there's another florida show
that i watch a lot
and it's a couple it's brad and lex
brad and lex do music
they're from florida here they're from
orlando also they do music reactions
and they're good too they're [ __ ]
funny
especially if you if you know the music
that they're reacting to because they're
young
and they don't really know the music
they try to understand they try to
figure out what the [ __ ] what the
lyrics mean and everything it's just
funny funny show
i can see why people like reaction
videos because young people they're
totally not tied up with that's what i'm
saying
well that's why and we talked about this
i talked about this on the goonies video
that i put up earlier today
was that i was really into
this dude who was my age and he had two
kids and he had watched goonies with his
kids
and i was curious as to like what his
kids who were ten and like seven and
eight i think seven or eight yeah uh
what they would think of that movie
because i said well they don't have any
like nostalgic bad baggage or anything
like that they weren't even remotely
alive when this movie came out uh and
both of them
loved it they thought it was fantastic
so
i because i'm very um
cognizant of the fact
that sometimes
a movie that you grew up with
as a child
uh you know it's awesome but like if
somebody that's
a kid like later sees it they're gonna
be like yeah that's really lame it's
like old people [ __ ]
so
i don't know i'm really cognizant of
that distinction but i'm interested in
how that plays out yeah
okay she added brad and lex yeah brad
i've talked i've talked to both brad and
lex behind the scenes and they they live
in orlando and i told him about
mannequins they want to come up to
mannequins one day and [ __ ] meet us
they've seen our show
oh [ __ ] that would be awesome yeah
okay brad and lex they're fun
they're they're young though they're the
young couple that's okay but they're
like we know lots of people what's funny
is that this [ __ ] remains true they they
said no that 80s music is better than
music of today they [ __ ] love 80s
music
and [ __ ] lex loves metal she that's
good because i don't want to feel like
an old person no i never wanted to be
like lex didn't know anything about
metal and then she started she really
started getting into into metal and but
brad is more into kind of like [ __ ] like
steely dan and blues and
he likes that soft rock
not wrong which is weird i wouldn't
think he'd like metal he's not big into
that he likes
sensitive stuff
but uh
sensitive
but they uh
nothing wrong with that they live in
they live in this area in um
in 1950
style trailer park
not a [ __ ] redneck
a 1950s style okay like you have done
you know how you're down here by the
little lake well like the air streams
with all those little [ __ ] airstreams
let me do it
and they're uh but man i don't
understand how long they're gonna be
living in that because they're filthy
rich now they're making [ __ ] [ __ ] ton
of money i've seen their live streams
and they'll pull down [ __ ] 600 bucks
on a live stream
nice yeah
so they're [ __ ] making big money
and then i'm [ __ ] looking at [ __ ]
looking at lex's [ __ ]
her damn schedule plan she's got all
those damn [ __ ] chalkboards you know
those uh it's you know not really
chalkboard anymore where you use the
pants the white board the white boards
yeah yeah huge white boards yeah she's
sitting there i have the i have the
month on it yeah she has that too with
all the movie reviews
and the book her white yeah because you
have to have schedules her whiteboard
yeah i have to know because i put up
videos early for patrons and so i have
to know like when everything goes up
yeah and when everything has to be
recorded and all that kind of stuff
lex's whiteboard schedule is the size of
this [ __ ] wall
because they have to [ __ ] keep track
of they got four three channels
and then the music channel they have to
have [ __ ] five or six songs a day and
then they live stream and then they talk
about
[ __ ] just regular [ __ ] you know what
i mean they did a dna test
and she came
she came back 27 [ __ ] european with
irish and german and [ __ ] brad came
back as about 20 26 25
[ __ ] european and she was like i
thought i was going to be a lot more
european than him because she's a lot
lighter skinned
and but it was just funny you know i
mean through what they're talking about
and then i was like well
in the comments like well this explains
why you like metal so much
but that's another that's another brand
you go you all need to follow brad and
lex that shit's a [ __ ] great those
three channels are great because they're
kind of like reality channels and every
day
they [ __ ] come up with some new [ __ ]
and they [ __ ] tell their [ __ ]
stories and it's a florida it's it's
funny they're funny
they're good people
good people
but that just goes to show yeah like
this is
my march
calendar yeah
which
that's all the movie reviews i'm putting
up right it's all the book reviews i'm
putting up
and then uh i fill in stuff as needed
right but
yeah i think people don't realize like
how much there's a lot of work in this
work that yeah you got to get it all
oriented yeah and it's like and it's
hard for me because it's like i'm smart
and everything but like i get uh i have
like panic attacks if i have like too
much stuff going on so i'm just kind of
like holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] like what the
[ __ ] so i have to do so i don't only
have that i also have like a uh like a
word document
that is a daily thing yeah this is
everything you have to do today put this
up
uh put this up for patreon post this for
public
uh upload this do this that that
so i have like that whole thing so it's
like a lot to keep track of well and
it's not just the show i also have
uh you know graphic design [ __ ] i have
to do i have like books should i have to
do i have like [ __ ]
other like [ __ ] administrative [ __ ] i
have to do like credit card bills i have
to pay and [ __ ] like that so it's like i
always put that on my daily [ __ ] yeah
they're talking about back when i used
to vape and [ __ ] in here yeah and then
[ __ ] uh dildo swagger says she just
bought your book jenny
oh thank you
tyler says i can't remember exactly when
i found tommy jenny all i remember is
that tom still had hair yeah and the
videos were about five frames per second
yeah yeah that was like the old
all right swag shragging about math
mountain mountain happened man
that that was that's some real [ __ ] the
only thing that i don't know if it
actually happens [ __ ] that
my cousin wesley
said that [ __ ] when when i r when we
re-interviewed him he would kind of gave
this weird story about he felt like
there was something flying over him when
he was trying to sleep i don't i don't
know about that but i know what he's
talking about there was a weird feeling
of presence in the house
now my aunt lois said she actually saw a
piece of [ __ ]
twist tie go right go i think it's in
the book though i said nah that didn't
happen
did you you did right i care well i
can't remember because i found it it was
it was already written it's just a long
time has passed by and she's she's older
now she's
almost pushing her 80s probably so and
red died and reds die he's dead now red
remembered more of it than i remembered
because we talked to him on the phone
some of that stuff that's in that book
was stuff that i had totally forgotten
about and red reminded me and it was
like oh man i started to have like
[ __ ] flashbacks
about the knife flying out from that
damn kitchen and almost hitting the
[ __ ]
slide yeah that was thing i didn't just
like go by his story no we talked to
lewis and red like on the phone like we
had them on speakerphone yeah
and it was like something out of a
[ __ ] horror movie man it was it was
it was bad man it was and looking back
on it
at the time i thought it was some kind
of [ __ ] ghost
but looking back on it it was it's
something
it's not it wasn't it was paranormal
definitely
but it wasn't supernatural it's
some having to physics would be able to
explain it eventually
it's
something having to do with uh
stuart haberoffs and and stewart
hammeroff's [ __ ] work with [ __ ]
consciousness
so in some ways in certain in certain
circumstances
the mind can
change matter
the only way i can describe it it's a
mind over matter type situation
having to do with [ __ ] stress
and it's not as rare it's it's not as
common as it used to mean
it used to it was always rare
but it's not as common as it used to be
i think
modern
society has
kind of nipped that in the bud
there was more of it happening in the
medieval period according to nip it in
the bud yeah jenny wrote another book
about all the old cases from the past
called unseen hand
mine isn't the only one you want to get
unseen hand also she'll talk about all
the other ones
that happened
some of them happened in japan
back in the 1700s kind of like that
didn't didn't you put that i think that
one's in there too wouldn't it
yeah i mean like the older ones there
wasn't a lot of info obviously right
uh
just stories about what people saw
but not
they're just stories i'm not falling
down on either side of the show right i
don't know what people i saw she she's
seen some of it but not as bad as it was
yeah
delishwagan says it's not too much
content but i do wish the episodes were
the topic were on topic yeah me too
um
he also says you guys come up with some
banger topics that only cover for like
shotgun last 30 minutes yeah
uh louis says extra movie reviews would
be awesome jenny i'm kind of thinking
about it i might do it
don't like count on it
but
today for example
i was like scrolling through some [ __ ]
because i was doing uh the poll for the
next week for patreon and i was just
kind of like man look at all these
[ __ ] movies man oh i need to watch
that again oh i need to watch that oh i
need to do that and it's like i need to
do all these reviews so i might just
start doing like [ __ ]
movie and book reviews like whenever and
just like putting them up whenever and
not really having a schedule
swagging and saying hey believes that
weird stuff happened when he was a kid
you talk about how weird that blood was
on the napkin yeah lois still has that
uh if i remember correctly we took she
took a photograph of it we put it in the
book yeah it's in there yeah
i haven't seen that in a long time
you know what's weird is that i could i
for some reason because i was younger
when i was young younger when it
happened
i can accept it a little bit better
red for all his life this this [ __ ]
scared the hell out of him he would get
real
quiet
and
scared to talking about this just
bringing it up
and he didn't talk about it much he
mostly talked about me when i'd call him
and when we did the book he hadn't
talked about it in a long time he was
affected very much affected by that
thing
he had a lot of more of a supernatural
view of it though he thought it was
[ __ ] a straight-up ghost or a demon
that's what he thought it was that was
the framework he was
working from
i don't think that's what it was though
rspk recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
that's what i think it was
from the subconscious mind
and somehow the mind or consciousness
can alter the state reality
can
seemingly move objects
and do weird things quickly
it was weird man it was very weird
the only other account that was close to
mine would have been the enfield
poltergeist
which you can see stuff on
youtube for that that happened too and
most of that happened some of that [ __ ]
the witnesses there were like nah
people reported that but we didn't see
that that probably didn't happen [ __ ]
like uh
um
her flying
you know only one person saw that
uh the voices that she could make
i don't think that was the dead i think
that was her subconscious
she was just freaking out
we
has to do it uh
kids going through puberty with a bunch
of [ __ ] internal turmoil
and uh
right place at the right time around the
right people the right just the right
synergy and it can happen you also have
to have a religious background you have
to believe in the
believe in the unseen have to
you have to be kind of a religious
family for it to happen and it doesn't
really matter the religion
i think same thing would happen in the
middle east they would just call it
gin
gin that's the each culture would call
it something else
good i'm done
dylan schwagen says i like your book
reviews jenny thank you
uh finding good books to read is a
hassle for me yeah me as well
i kind of like try to go to other
uh you know book review channels that
i'm into and i kind of
but i i use like amazon recommendations
also
the one that i'm reading now
actually the one that i'm doing the
review i already recorded it but it's
going up like uh
the first week of april
was a short story compilation that was
called the wide carniver sky by john
legend
and somebody suggested that to me i
don't remember who it was but that was
excellent very love crafty and if you're
into that so i did a review of that the
book i'm reading now
i'm not done with it
but
i'm really into it so far it's really
good
um it's adam neville he was the same guy
that wrote no one gets out alive which i
reviewed a while back
this one is called um what is it called
cunning folk
it's like a folk horror type of
situation and i'm really really digging
it so far i don't know how it's gonna go
i don't know if it's gonna be good i'm
about twenty percent of the way into it
humbly ebook but yeah uh tila says jenny
you all have to see x
it's thai west best just go out and
enjoy yourself honestly
ty west uh he yeah who's a horror
director okay he made
the innkeepers he made house of the
devil he made like a lot of good horror
movies he has a new movie out called x
which i told you i wanted to see okay um
it's playing yeah we gotta go see uh
the batman batman too
but
like i said i wanted to go see x but we
haven't seen it yet so
we haven't seen it yeah we have a studio
i know but yeah i do want to see it
um
yeah but that's one thing that i want to
say holy parish of doom says i stumbled
onto 13 o'clock
as a suggestion
because i run a heavy metal channel so
i'm uploading every week it came as a
suggestion dig the channel name we
actually like uh
we came upon that because i said
let's name it after that clock that's in
the honda mansion at disney
that's not how i remembered it
yeah i remembered it naming it after the
[ __ ] clock that was in the labyrinth
no
okay it was haunted mansion okay
it was time to manchester
i absolutely remember the conversation
that we had about this okay
i said you know how in the haunted
mansion
all right at disney
they have that clock
that goes to 13
when you go buy it in the car
all right and i was like let's call it
that
josie says that uh it what do you say
about
it's just looking at carl young's the
shadow if i remember correctly it's the
manifestation of the evil ones yeah we
did a show on carl young
and uh yeah i kind of agree with carl
young and
that's
he's describing kinda
he's pretty much describing what i'm
talking about
yeah jungian stuff
but he's very um it's not a very
scientific description it's more poetic
and philosophical but you know that'll
fit that'll fit it's what it is probably
i mean i don't know for sure even though
it happened to me but i'm just saying
it's something like that it's the
unconscious
you guys says jenny have you guys
considered doing movie reactions we have
thought about doing like movie like
watchalongs but
i don't know i kind of feel like that
might be a good idea because i have to
say
sometimes when we watch a movie
especially if it's like a shitty one we
make some like super funny comments yeah
and
sometimes we're gonna do a rip trip when
we make super funny comments i'm like
why wasn't that recorded because that
[ __ ] was hilarious and everybody missed
out on that [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] sexual at
least when i say
talking to people's booties that's okay
boobs
i don't know i kind of feel like yeah
we're just like are you trying to give
head just just funny [ __ ] we should do
that yeah um
i do kind of feel like we we will get
into that at some point we will get it
right
uh dildo schweigen says i'm big into
lovecraft it would be cool if he could
recommend more of that genre honestly
like the book that i just read uh
wide carnivore sky
it's a short story collection
i don't want to say short story it's
mostly like novellas there's only like
uh nine stories in there most of them
are very long
but
it does have a very lovecraftian vibe
too
i was really into it i'll make a
recommendation outside of lovecraft
though it's gonna come an upcoming show
is going to be about this
i'm listening to the audiobook right now
years back i wrote i read gaston larose
phantom of the opera
of the original
and it started off the prologue and
everything
and i was convinced that he was talking
about a real case
it turns out i did some more research
recently because me and jenny were
talking about it and i went and looked
back into it
gassed in a row swore up and down
that that might win for the next okay
it's it's ahead i checked today and it's
ahead on his deathbed guest in the rose
swore that that was a real case that he
investigated that the phantom of the
opera did happen
when i was reading it i was believing it
i read it in probably about 2005
and the reason why i believe it is
because he's describing a serial killer
long before profiling was around
and he's describing things that if i
remember correctly i mean
i remember him describing
uh the the phantom looking like like a
kid that i
remember from school
who had some kind of weird disease
but i haven't i'm going back into the
audio book this time
and i'm waiting for the description to
come back up i don't know if i
remembered this
the description accurately or not we'll
see what he's described at because he
was described by one characters that he
didn't have a nose
and i don't didn't remember that okay if
he didn't have a nose they might be
talking about leprosy
but um
some of the story some of some of the
details of that story sound [ __ ]
far-fetched i was like oh that could
never happen it's got to be [ __ ]
false
but it turns out those are absolutely
true there was
that that that theater did burn down on
the give it on the date that it said
there was an underground lake underneath
the
the theater that did have
a [ __ ] island on it
and on that island evidently the
so-called phantom
had built basically a mansion on it
and he was an architect
that had come from the middle east
he was from france but he was living in
the middle east as a torturer for some
kind of sultan and an architect for
assault
making his battlements and making stuff
for him he became amazingly rich and
moved back to france and bought this
theater so he could stalk girls starring
in the theater
and man and then the way it's described
in the book i'm like man this is a
serial killer you're talking about
you're talking about [ __ ] um
uh what was the dude that made the damn
castle
um
what was the serial killer the murder
cat h h homes yeah you're talking about
like a h homes type of guy
but evidently according to gaston
was a was a uh not only an architect and
a genius but also a musical genius who
could sing and who could write music
which there's nothing really
that's that's that's that's possible
that's possible that's not impossible
well
i'm just gonna say like today i looked
at the patreon poll
and that
topic is winning this wedding yeah okay
so we might do a whole topic who might
do a whole show about that
i made it through the first hour of the
real story behind phantom of the yeah
there there's several oh you want us to
talk about that
go to patreon
and sign up yeah and vote for it there's
several audio books
of the phantom of the opera one of them
is nine hours long
and it's a girl and she reads everything
including the prologue i mean if that
wins i'm gonna listen to that so
another one is about four hours long and
it's got christopher lee writing it
reading it and that one's pretty good
but it left out a lot of the details
that i remember reading
the nine hour one has just got a girl
reading it and she's just like just some
girl reading it
um what i did was is i listened to the
girl read the prologue and then i went
to go listen to the christopher lee one
well if you have a chance to listen to
christopher right
he puts on a great show
but uh i kind of like thinking maybe i
would go back and just listen to the
nine-hour one with the girls well just
listen to the whole thing that way that
way i get everything yeah because that's
what i read well like i said if that
wins in the poll
i'll find out on sunday
uh then i will also listen to the whole
thing i'll remember or read it i'll
probably just read it i remember around
2005
walking away from gaston larose
phantom of the opera book
thinking that's something that happened
that had to have happened
and then people reassured people assured
me no that's fiction
this is before wikipedia you know what i
mean and i was like i don't know man
that sounds like something that happened
and now on wikipedia it says that
[ __ ] gaster monroe assures assured
people on his deathbed that that really
did happen
and in the prologue he talks about his
investigation of it he went there to
investigate and and what witnesses he
collected and
who told him and
where they went and
so i think it did happen
well we'll see i think it did happen it
looks like that might win yeah i kind of
hope it does
you're right i'm not like trying to like
if y'all are patrons i'm not like trying
to like yeah influence your decision and
here's the thing that's because there's
a lot of good topics in there here's the
weird thing about the phantom of the
opera nowadays if you were to tell some
young girl we do something about the
founder of she thinks it's a romance
that is not what the book was
in the book the [ __ ] eric who was the
phantom was a straight up [ __ ] serial
killer yeah it's not a robot he was a
murderer that's [ __ ] up yeah
he had a torture rooms and all kinds of
a weird stalker and he was just yeah
yeah yeah he was a bad dude it was bad
it was bad he wasn't some romantic i
love you yeah i love you but if you
reject me i'll [ __ ] kill you that's
that he was one of those not fine yeah
he had [ __ ]
torture rooms set up with [ __ ]
razor sharp metallic trees that rotated
and inside glass rooms that got to 200
degrees it would dehydrate you he's like
an insulin [ __ ] yeah he was like
i didn't sell right
like i'm all romantic until you don't
love me back then i kill you oh and then
i kill your boyfriend right yeah he's
one of those that was that that's not so
funny
uh louis says jenny what's your email
again i have two uh easiest one to
remember probably
is gravecake
gmail.com
uh i have another one but it's harder to
remember so i just said it
uh 13 o'clock is used by orwell in 1984.
yeah i forgot about that
honestly we were thinking about it
he remembers it
like i remember we were talking about it
and i said
we were talking about um
we never even thought about doing a
podcast
we were at
a horror convention like it wasn't even
a convention it was like a little bit of
thing at a comic book store we were
selling our books
and
uh what's his what's his name
what's that horror writer
what's his name which one
the one that was at the uh the comic con
at the comic store they wrote what
he wrote a zombie what's this [ __ ] oh
god damn it okay so he was there
and he says to us
uh because we were selling some books
and stuff and he was like you guys are
really funny
uh you guys should do a podcast to like
help sell your books
this was back in
2016. it was a while back
we had never really thought about it and
we were just kind of like
to him maybe i was just going the guy
that we went on his network for a while
yeah yeah yeah i forgot what his name
was yeah yeah i'll i'll remember to say
yeah
he's he's a pretty well he had 50 000
people on his network but no interaction
that's true that's what he said
so yeah we did have like a lot of
downloads but yeah
um so
there was that so i was just kind of
like i never thought about it but i was
just kind of like oh that's a good idea
and
tom's funny i was like i'm kind of funny
and you know we could be funny together
it would be good
and so we started doing the show
we started doing like paranormal stuff i
kind of feel like that was like our inn
and then we slowly got into doing
uh
you know more true crime stuff which is
more my thing
and then we started doing like horror
movie reviews a little bit later which
again was more my thing
but
that's kind of how it started like we
never even really thought about doing a
podcast before
yeah until somebody suggested it
hey you guys are funny yeah together
like the way you guys interact is funny
that was in a time when a podcast and a
youtube show they were [ __ ] a new
phenomenon
yeah that was like back in like early
2016. yeah they were around but they
weren't that wasn't considered a joke
and we were just like
we were just like in real time i still
had a real job at that time and it's
like and we were like at a
we were at a convention like selling
books yeah and tom was like huckstering
like selling my pokestreet
well you know
uh it wasn't hug string i was selling
yeah he was selling my books yeah and so
like it was being like a [ __ ] barker
right the guy that set up was like he
noticed and he was just kind of like hey
you guys are like really funny together
so
you and i should do a show and he had a
network at the time and he's like you
know come on our show and it's like you
know for a while we were on their
network
but that's kind of how we got started we
never really like thought about doing a
podcast before that yeah
i mean i kind of feel like maybe that's
more like your thing because i don't
really like
i got over it i don't mind it now
because you guys are all here and you
guys are lovely
um
when we first started doing the live
[ __ ] when we just started doing the live
[ __ ] at like the 200th episode i was
terrified
yeah i was like i do not want to do a
live show all right tyler the guy says i
know very little of the fan of the opera
but you guys are getting me seriously
interested in this and he says they
should make a fan of the opera movie
this full-on horror movie oh they did
they have but they're kind of terrible
yeah the very first one a lot of them
were terrible the very first one was a
full-on horror movie
but the original
lon chaney but the original copy doesn't
exist and there's about five different
versions of that film and none of them
are really complete some of them are
missing dialogue and all kinds of it's
funny how they did that
um what i recommend is to go on youtube
and listen to the audio books
that long one that just has the girl
kind of reading it dry
that's their that's the origin that's
the full book
the full book without the
prologue and without the index it's like
127 pages it's really not that long
but for some reason the audience yeah i
could read that like in an hour
yeah the audio book though i think it
was like six seven eight hours
i don't really know why
the uh
that one is more complete because it
gives some of the background
and the prologue
uh the um
uh what's that what's the uh the guys
the [ __ ] british guy [ __ ] [ __ ]
christopher lee christopher lee the
christopher lee version is like
three hours
um that one's i've listened to them both
that's the fun reading
but it leaves a lot of the details out
that gaston said
gustin tells you how he
investigated the case it's a serial
killer case it's something like h.h
holmes that happened
he is and evidently he assured people on
his deathbed that it was a real murder
that he saw the letters and everything
it happened in the late 1800s he did the
investigation in the
1906 around that time
or he wrote the book in 1906 was it but
was he doing some found footage [ __ ]
because that that was very people
thought that people that was very
popular people thought that
but here's the thing
that theater did burn down on the given
day
there is an underground lake underneath
there with the [ __ ]
underneath it with uh
with an island on it
he says that they were bodies they found
the bodies that he
that uh
he took an expedition down there and
that they they they collected some some
skeletons some bones
that's that's what he said
rebecca says ever done a book review on
the flowers in the attic book series i
haven't
uh i've read the first
two or three of those
um
i have like the first movie it's not
great
but
i have like a weird
guilty pleasure thing about it
it's kind of terrible
even though like [ __ ] louise fletcher
isn't it but
uh so there's that i don't know i might
there's a lot of books
i read the first
two or three
and they're very um
they're good but they're really um
what's the word i'm looking for
they're a little uh unsavory let's say
that there's a lot of like [ __ ] weird
underage
kind of stuff going on it but you know
i kind of everybody liked him back in
the day
uh yeah so tyler's like they should make
a fan of the opera movie okay so
they've made a lot of phantom of the
opera movies
uh one of the more recent ones well it's
not that recent but dario argento made
one
uh with his daughter ozzy in it i think
it was in the 90s or maybe the early
2000s
it was not that great i kind of feel
like
they try to make that [ __ ] a romance and
that is not what the book was
that's well that's what i mean i kind of
feel like maybe
don't do that no because that's like
really not with the
i feel like that wasn't really the
original intention
of that story gaston
gaston is
he is
telling the audience that he
did the investigation
20 years after it happened
that it was a difficult investigation
because most of the people involved had
moved away so a lot of them had died
uh he was able to find a manager that
managed the place during that time who
remembered it had some letters
between
the phantom and the girl
and he assured him
gaston that it was real
and then later on
he ended up going into the underground
lake that it was there
and they found bones on the [ __ ]
island that was there
and that he went down there with a bunch
of other people that they that they had
in the authorities and that they had
evidently
confirmed that yeah that this [ __ ]
happened and it happened 20 years prior
to him going there
and that it did that the that parts of
the theater did burn down
most of the people were gone
involved in it
but he had heard a lot of it through the
manager and that's what made him write
the book
based on what the manager had told him
and some other people
he tracked down a couple other ones
and he tried to put together
what had happened
and what he's talking about is something
kind of like h.h holmes
a serial killer
but like i said now i'm kind of hoping
that that wins because yeah if that wins
we could do a whole show about that yeah
and we could talk about that that'd be
super cool i bought it
i know that they used to do found
footage type [ __ ] dracula was a found
footage type book well it was epistolary
meaning everything was like in was in
letter or journal forms the thing is is
that i'm reading the book they knew
about found footage [ __ ] they didn't
have video back then but it was the same
thing where they were trying to make
everything seem like it was real
um
they were not uh
they knew what that concept was
we're trying to make everything seem
real as possible i'm reading through the
phantom of the opera as i remember it
back in like 2005 or six
going wait a minute hold on wait a
minute wait a minute in the descriptions
that are happening of the offender i'm
like
wait a minute they didn't know that kind
of stuff back then he's they're
perfectly describing a serial killer
perfectly
and the [ __ ] thinking in the
background
and um
you know
that and this is long before profiling
so well the thing about profiling serial
killer is what they're talking about i
mean not to [ __ ] on profiling but if you
know about
um how [ __ ] up people can be
yeah it's kind of like common sense it
look you know what i mean it just
yeah
you can figure it out from that
is all i'm saying well okay you're
saying a mitigating circumstances is it
was france
it was france 1880s or two or at least
1906 that's when the book came out
maybe in france in 1906 there's enough
there to put together a uh a credible
serial killer story
maybe
when when was h.h holmes
i would 20s 20s okay i would compare
well whenever the uh world's fair in
chicago went i don't know when that was
i would compare
what i remember i think it was early
1920s or
late but i would remember of the phantom
of the opera story
i would put that on par with h.h helms
so
in terms of credibility and the things
that he did
about like hh shows building buildings
having lots of money
um
making torture chambers uh getting away
with a bunch of [ __ ] well he says oh
1882
like earlier chicago world's fair okay
1882 okay so that was earlier than okay
so
could have been that they used to hate
20th century maybe they used h8 maybe
gaston used [ __ ] hh homes as a
[ __ ] template this sounds like h.h
holm city who he's talking about
in the phantom of the opera
except he's horribly dis disfigured but
he's a genius
which makes it worse
okay that had he been a dumb
[ __ ] he would have lived in
obscurity and never no one's interested
in dumb nobody yes but he would have
lived in obscurity and he wouldn't have
had the ambitions of a super [ __ ]
intelligent dude who who felt that he
was being denied greatness a guy who
could not a man who could not grasp a
musical genius
and because of his physical [ __ ]
deformity you know what i mean it was
this the physical deformity that was
holding him back from greatness which
[ __ ] causes this
more suffering and more [ __ ] conflict
within him that turns him into a monster
that's what the story said i gotta see
it again though this is all based on
memories from a long time ago mary
connolly said he was a doctor who h.h
holmes
um or a quasi doctor sort of sort of
a doctor didn't mean much in the 1800s
i think he actually did and please
forgive me it's been a long time since
i've looked into it he did i think he
did
graduate from medical school but
yeah at the time that doesn't mean the
same thing that it would mean nowadays
medical school didn't take long
and didn't it wasn't really that big of
a deal
anybody could anybody with money and
half of brains could graduate from
medical school medical school back then
went much to it
i mean and honestly i have to say
i think a lot of the stuff about hh
homes i'm not saying that
a lot of it didn't happen
but i think a lot of it was probably
exaggerated
all the stuff about
the secret passages and like the [ __ ]
room maybe he did do that stuff but
i don't know
i kind of feel like
it might have been like exaggerated holy
parish of doom called he says pull the
strings
pull the strings that's exactly right
pull the strings
oh my goodness yeah
[Laughter]
louie said would he be like a modern
pharmacist no no i mean well yeah maybe
maybe
although i kind of feel like pharmacists
nowadays would have more like education
than maybe he had
maybe
because back in those days like i said
i'm not saying anybody could go to
medical school but there was a lot less
to learn back then yeah a lot less it
was a lot easier much easier
um and back in those days
if you [ __ ] up in one state you could
just change your name and move to
another state and you can start all over
which you can't really do nowadays
because of
various other things but yeah you could
do that back then
and honestly
like reading about [ __ ] back then it's
like look he just moved to another state
he changed his name he like married
other people yeah nobody knew about like
the whole family he had back in the old
all the people he killed in this old
state
it's like [ __ ] holy crap i don't know
so what time is it jeff how long have
you been streaming
um four hours and times twenty three
minutes time to go it's been a while 10
17 pm let's go ahead and shut it down
it's been a long show you can make me
some food yeah maybe some food let me
just wait what are you gonna make i'll
see what's oh i got i got all kinds of
stew down there i got turkeys too still
oh can i have some chocolate yeah all
right yeah oh my god we'll eat some of
that yeah you guys we had this we had
this whole turkey yeah uh which we
bought at what like before thanksgiving
right yeah
we bought a whole bunch frozen and we
froze it and then like the tur the
freezer started to go bad started
fritzing out yeah and so the turkey kind
of thawed out yeah so we had to cook it
yeah
i chopped it up in the quarters and [ __ ]
so we cooked it and it's like a couple
times we had like a thanksgiving kind of
thing where it was like turkey and
potatoes and stuff yeah that got old but
then he's like yeah i'm sick of that so
last night he's like [ __ ] it i'm gonna
make cream of turkey soup stew and stew
like you put like potatoes and celery
potatoes and salad turkey and it's like
carrots and it's really really yeah it's
really imagine turkey dinner but in a
stew yeah it's good over rice
yeah yeah so that's what we're going to
have yeah we have some of this okay go
ahead and shut it down okay
so
thank you everybody for dropping by
thank you for spreading spending your
spreading spring
spending your friday night with us
this evening and we will be back on
sunday talking about a movie we don't
know which one yet because we haven't
watched it
but
hopefully you guys will join us on
sunday evening or afternoon or what the
[ __ ] ever
and thanks everybody for coming by we're
gonna go eat now
and we will see you on sunday
bye